Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 138. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ja, heute geht's mal wieder in die praktische Welt. Ein Thema steht auf der Liste, wo jeder mitmachen kann. Das ist immer was Schönes, nicht immer diese abgehobene Scheiße von so Sachen, die dann eh keiner versteht, sondern wir wollen jetzt hier in die Praxis gehen. Und ich begrüße zwei Gäste, und zwar zur Linken Frank Rieger, hallo und Philip Steffan, hallo. Und ihr seid einiges, aber unter anderem seid ja, naja, so Bastelnerds, richtig? Sachen selber machen, aber es geht doch schon deutlich über das Stricken hinaus.
Na ja, was wir halt machen, ist halt Sachen selber bauen, die man vorher nicht so ohne weiteres selber machen konnte, sondern im Laden kaufen musste. Und der Reiz dabei ist halt vielfältiger, da wollen wir heute ein bisschen drüber reden. Unter anderem ist es auch sehr entspannend, also einfach Sachen selber bauen, wenn man den ganzen Tag nur Bits geschubst hat, und dann abends nochmal was in die Hand nehmen, wo man hinterher sieht, was das Ergebnis ist, was man sich entfassen kann und nach Hause nehmen kann. Das ist halt auch schön.
Manchmal sind es ja auch Geräte, die man doch nicht im Laden kaufen kann, oder nicht so. Dann bleibt einem auf dir auch nichts anderes übrig, als zu sagen, das muss jetzt einfach selbst gemacht werden, das gibt es eigentlich nicht.
Genau. Und noch so ein anderes Ding ist, viele Sachen kann man einfach auch nicht selber kaufen, jedenfalls nicht für bezahlbares Geld, weil sie halt irgendwie zu Tode patentiert oder nur für bestimmte Märkte gedacht sind, die halt dem normalen Endverbraucher nicht offen stehen. Und dann muss man es halt einfach selber bauen. Dann ist es halt auch total schön, dass man den Patent da einfach als Quelle der Information betrachten kann und nicht als Hürde. Weil für persönliche Benutzung kann man ja bauen, was man will, da gibt es ja keine Hürde. Man verletzt der Patente nur, wenn man Produkte baut, die man dann auch verkauft. Aber für sich selber kann man halt einfach tun, was man möchte.
Genau, damit kommen wir auch so etwa auf den Scope dieser Sendung zu sprechen. Es geht hier eigentlich um High-Tech-Do-It-Yourself-Sachen-Bauen, die schon so eine gewisse technologische Herausforderung darstellen und jetzt über das normale Basselspielzeug zur Adventszeit hinausgehen.
Ja, wir basteln auch Adventssachen. Also, na Gott, das Schöne ist halt, am Ende geht es ja tatsächlich um Demokratisierung von Produktionsmitteln. Also darum, dass man selber in die Lage versetzt wird, Dinge zu produzieren, indem man sich zum Beispiel zusammentut und halt einen Raum mietet oder Räume mietet und sich Produktionsmittel zusammenkauft, die man sich vorher einfach nicht hätte leisten können. Weil alleine kann man sich zum Beispiel keine CNC-Fräse kaufen. Also kann man zwar schon, aber das ist man halt arm. Wenn man das so zähend macht, dann ist das halt völlig unproblematisch. Und man nutzt das so ein Ding sowieso alleine nie aus. Also tut man sich halt zusammen und macht halt solche Dinge zusammen. Also wir haben zum Beispiel in Berlin so ein Ding, das heißt Raumfahrtagentur, das ist halt so ein kleiner Hacker-Space mit momentan acht oder neun Mitgliedern, so zehn könnten wir aufnehmen. Wo wir so einen gewissen Fokus haben, sind halt in dem Fall Elektrofahrräder, reden vielleicht später noch drüber. Aber auch ganz andere Sachen machen, alles was uns halt so in den Sinn kommt. Und der Drive dahinter war halt einfach zu sagen, wir wollen eine gemeinsame Werkstatt haben, wir wollen Dinge gemeinsam tun, sich auch gegenseitig inspirieren, gemeinsam die Werkzeuge besitzen und am Leben halten, um Sachen zu machen, die man alleine einfach nicht machen kann. Und die man auch nicht in einem kommerziellen Kontext machen würde, weil dann sieht es halt wieder ganz anders aus. Da muss ich plötzlich Gewinn abwerfen und all diese ganzen Dinge.
Bleiben wir mal kurz bei der Raumfahrt Agentur. Also elektrische Fahrräder, du hast ja gesagt, das ist bei euch ein Thema. War hier auch schon ein Thema, und zwar mit Gizmo, der bei euch ja auch mitbastelt. Chaosradio Express 65, da ging es sozusagen um den Stand der Technik. Ich glaube, da hat sich auch eine Menge getan. Da müssen wir halt mal über ein Update nachdenken. Und was du auch erwähnt hast, Hacker Spaces, war ja auch schon mal ein Thema. CAE 134, wo wir auch schon quasi diese Bestandsaufnahme gemacht haben, dieses Movements, dass einfach dieses, na wie soll man sagen, auf der einen Seite hatten wir natürlich so 80er, 90er Jahre diese starken Individualisierungsentwicklungen. Jeder kann halt zu Hause die Dinge machen und man muss jetzt nicht mehr irgendwo hingehen. Und dann saßen alle in ihrem Keller und haben irgendwie gemacht. Und jetzt merkt man im Prinzip schon fast wieder so eine Gegenbewegung, die allerdings auch, naja, in meinen Augen komplementär ist, also die sozusagen noch dazukommt, dass man eben dann auch den Keller immer wieder verlässt. Und vielleicht eben dann den modernen Hobbykeller gründet eben mit anderen Leuten, so wie er es bei der Raumfahrtagentur gemacht hat. Beziehungsweise wie auch viele dieser Hacker-Spaces, nicht alle. Manche sind ja auch eher, sagen wir mal, mehr so, wie soll man sagen, also nicht so sehr auf Hardware-Basteln konzentriert. Genau, so ein bisschen virtuellere Natur, schön gesagt.
Das Schöne ist halt, ein Hardware, das fördert halt tatsächlich die Zusammenarbeit noch mehr als bei Software. Eine Menge Sachen sind halt einfach Erfahrung, teilweise auch motorische Erfahrung, also Sachen, wo man halt einfach schon ein paar Mal gemacht haben muss. Einfaches Beispiel, vor einem Jahr hätte ich mir nie auf die Idee gekommen, dass ich in der Lage wäre, in einem Nachmittag ein komplettes Fahrradrad selber einzuspeichen, auszurichten, aufzuziehen und einzubauen. Das hätte ich als Wochenendprojekt mit viel Hilfe betrachtet. Und nicht, als mach ich immer eben so. Und das ist halt so ein Erfahrungsding, dass man halt einfach, wenn man es ein paar Mal gemacht hat und da schon jemand dabei ist, der das auch schon mal gemacht hat, dann kann man sich halt helfen und über die Schulter schauen und so. Und das ist halt noch sehr viel mehr hands-on, als das bei Software der Fall ist, wo man doch eher dazu tendiert, in How-To's zu blättern oder Foren zu lesen oder dergleichen Dinge mehr. Und so ist das halt ein sehr viel kooperativere und praktische Komponente, das Hardware-Basteln. Zumindest meiner Erfahrung nach.
Du machst ja auch schon seit längerer Zeit Ähnliches. Da gibt es dieses Baustellen-Projekt.
Genau.
Was steckt denn in den Namen drin?
Der Name, ausgedacht von Blom Blom Blom, der ja auch hier schon war, ist natürlich Bauen und Basteln drin und so ein bisschen Alliteration oder Baustelle und sowas. Die Idee war eigentlich, dass wir so ein geiles Wort gerne hätten wie Make, so im Englischen, und dass irgendwie alle deutschen Worte scheiße sind, weil die irgendwie machen es nicht das Richtige und fummeln. Alles andere klingt so kindisch. Und dann hat sich in irgendeiner nächtlichen Chat-Session irgendwie dieses Wort ergeben. Und da habe ich mich dann über den Verlauf von mehreren Wochen irgendwie dran gewöhnt, meinen Frieden gemacht. Und ja, jetzt heißt das so. Und was das eigentlich sein soll, ist immer noch auch so, also das Do-It-Yourself, dieses ganze Projekt atmet auch so. Do-It-Yourself, da ich nicht immer genau weiß, ist das jetzt schon 100 Prozent alles. Also Webseite auf Deutsch gucken, dass man Informationen ranbringt.
Also baustellen.de. Und welche Funktion hat diese Webseite?
Sie ist noch nicht so, wie ich mir das wünsche. Es sollte eigentlich eher so magazinmäßig werden, was natürlich wie immer bei Inhalten mit Zeit verbunden ist, die dann noch nicht so ganz da ist. Dann haben wir sozusagen, ich bin eigentlich, hatte ich auch tatsächlich angefangen mit der Idee eines Ortes. Also das kam so nach dem letzten Kongress, so aus der Zusammenwirkung verschiedener Inspirationen, so natürlich, dass die Amerikaner, die jetzt den Make-Up-Out machen, Davan, Zack und Bre, so Geschichten wie dieses Buch Marke Eigenbau, was ja auch rausgekommen ist irgendwie so vor einem dreiviertel Jahr.
Von wem jetzt?
Das ist Holm Fribe und Thomas Ramge. Das ist halt aus dem CIA.
Zentrale Intelligenz Agentur.
Genau, Dunstkreis. Und da geht es halt auch relativ früh sozusagen, sage ich mal, darum, wo das jetzt so eine Art Trend ist. Oder vielleicht auch nicht. Wie geht das denn alles weiter mit diesem Do-it-yourself und so? Und dann dachte ich, okay, da gibt es schon ein Buch darüber. Online finde ich bisher nur Sachen, die sehr auf Englisch sind oder sehr spezialisiert. Ich versuche mich immer, dieses Thema anzunehmen. Und da stand ganz am Anfang auch klar die Idee, warum braucht ein Ort, weil Dinge online zu beschreiben, man könnte ja und so weiter, das ist nicht so ganz befriedigend.
Also nichts funktioniert so gut wie die Macht des praktischen Beispiels. Und das war für uns dann halt auch die Idee halt zu sagen, also wir tun uns halt zusammen und mieten halt einfach so einen kleinen Laden und gucken mal, was dann passiert. Und am Ende hängt natürlich davon ab, mit welchen Leuten man das macht. Man will halt auch schon mit Leuten zusammen machen, von denen man weiß, dass sie zum Beispiel, wenn sie ein Werkzeug kaputt machen, einfach mal Bescheid sagen und sagen, hey, ich hab's kaputt gemacht und nicht irgendwie mit Klebeband zusammenfrickeln und irgendwo in der Ecke verstecken. Und dann ärgert man sich nächstes Mal, wenn man es braucht. Das ist halt ein ganz wichtiger Punkt. Man braucht halt schon so einen gewissen Kontext, auf den man sich verlassen kann. Das ist halt schon relativ wichtig. In den USA gibt es ja dieses Modell, so eine Art Fitnessstudio für Making zu machen. Also da gibt es halt so eine große Werkstatt mit allerhand Maschinen und Werkzeugen, wo dann halt so betreutes Basteln ist. Da kann man dann so für 100 Dollar im Monat Mitglied werden.
Da wird man so richtig an eine Maschine eingewiesen, wie sonst am Laufband oder was?
Genau, es gibt halt dann so Trainingskurse, wo du halt irgendwie, weißt du, da kriegst du dann halt deinen Drehmaschinenschein und da gibt es dann halt so allerhand lustige Dinge. Also hast du dann so ein FID-Kartchen, mit dem du halt deine Maschine freischalten kannst. Und auf dem Kartchen ist vermarkt, ob du schon an diese Maschine eingewiesen wurdest. Und so eine Sache ist halt so ein... Das ist dieses Tech-Shop-Dinger. Genau, diese Tech-Shop-Dinger. Da gibt es ja mehrere Clones von.
Tech-Shop heißt das.
Und da gibt es... Also Clore 6 oder so gibt es mittlerweile. Das ist schon relativ groß geworden. Die interessante Frage ist, ob so etwas halt auch in Deutschland funktionieren würde. Das wissen wir nicht. Aber es würde wahrscheinlich dann auch eher so in der 100 Euro pro Monat-Kategorie sein. Weil natürlich dann schon die Anzahl der Leute, die mitmachen würden, einschränkter.
Also ist das dann schon so richtig Business sozusagen?
Genau. Weil da brauchst du natürlich Leute, die da sind. Also die halt einfach da den Fitnessstudio-Betreuer machen.
Wie gesagt, das geht auch ganz gut zusammen. Wie gesagt, als ich mich so ein bisschen von einem Jahr weiter gebildet habe, bin ich ja dann auch über diese ganzen Hallenprojekt-Geschichten gelaufen. Also diese Idee des Coworkings, was ja auch so ein bisschen durch Friotons geschrieben wurde in letzter Zeit. Gibt es ja im Betahaus und im Oberholz sitzen ja auch hier in Berlin angeblich oder tatsächlich immer alle, die nicht zu Hause sitzen wollen mit ihrer selbstständigen Arbeit, sondern machen das gemeinsam. Das ist denn keine Hands-on-Arbeit, sondern eher jeder mit dem Laptop. Aber natürlich entsteht da über dem Schreibtisch weg natürlich auch irgendwas, dass jemand sagt, ach du kannst sowas und ich brauche jemand, der das macht und so weiter. Und das hatte ich mir damals eingeguckt und dachte, ja ist ja schön, dass die das machen. Das ist mir aber zu wenig. Das müsste man so zusammenbringen mit dieser Hacker-Spaces-Idee.
Was ist dir konkret zu wenig? Also was jetzt alle diese Sachen? Vielleicht müssen wir mal kurz ein bisschen... Also Hallenprojekt hast du erwähnt. Das ist hier... Ist was genau?
Hallenprojekt ist ein Projekt und eine Webseite, die sozusagen die Idee hat, diese Coworking-Orte, also Orte, an denen man halt gemeinschaftlich arbeiten kann, erstmal im weitesten Sinne, zu inspirieren und zu vernetzen.
Ok, also es ist selber kein Ort?
Nee, genau.
So ähnlich wie Baustellen versucht, die Idee des Bastelns zu verbreiten, war Hallenprojekt sozusagen der Idee des Coworkings verbunden?
Wie gesagt, da hängen ja auch die Leute drin, die ich kenne und auch gesagt hat Christian Heller, ich grüße dich.
Oh, jetzt war auch grüße bei Chaosradio.
Ja, also erstmalig. Und das Tolle fand ich ja, dass es schön ist, dann sozusagen einfach so einen Ort zu haben. Das ist natürlich auch so eine Art Fitnessstudio, nur fürs Arbeiten vielleicht. Oder jedenfalls dieses Modell. Und dann dachte ich, ist ja doof, dass ich da dann aber nicht irgendwie noch was löten kann oder noch was schweißen kann oder so. Und dann hab ich mal dieses Konzept reingeguckt, was dahinter steckt mit diesem ganzen, wo auch dieser Begriff Halle kommt. Und im Wesentlichen im alten Konzept stand ja drin. Ja, das ist ein Ort, wo alle Arbeiten gemacht werden. Das geht eigentlich sehr in vorindustrielle Zeit so von der Idee her. Und das ist irgendwie auch, Hackerspace ist einfach von anderen Richtungen formuliert.
Also im weiteren Sinne kann man schon festhalten, es geht eigentlich um so eine moderne Form der Kollaboration. Man will irgendwie nicht unbedingt in seinem eigenen Büro abhängen, sondern man will auch von anderen lernen, mit anderen lernen. Und das kann sich eigentlich auf alles erweitern. Also einerseits Co-Working ist ja vor allem auch erstmal Working. Das heißt, da geht es ja schon darum, dass die Leute eigentlich ihrem normalen Business nachgehen, was auch immer das sein mag. Und dann hin zu den anderen Projekten, wo es dann eher mehr so um die Hobby-Natur geht.
Das ist ja ohnehin dir ein interessantes Kennzeichen dieser ganzen Bewegung, dass dir die Grenze zwischen Business und Hobby sehr fließend ist. Das heißt also, das, was bei Software ohnehin schon immer so war und bei Webdesign und diesen ganzen Dingen, das ist eher so ein bisschen unscharf war, ob jetzt jemand gerade tatsächlich für Geld arbeitet oder für sich arbeitet, erweitert sich da halt auf den physischen Raum. Und dadurch, dass man, wenn man Produktionsmittel gemeinsam besitzt, muss man natürlich Regeln dafür finden, wie es ist, wenn jemand damit kommerzielle Dinge tut, ob er dann mehr irgendwie in die Gemeinschaftskasse tut oder nicht so. Also da gibt es einen interessanten Raum von Regeln, die noch gefunden werden müssen. Aber in der Regel ist es sehr viel entspannter als zu früheren Zeiten, wo es dann immer gleich feste Prozentzahlen und irgendwie diese ganzen Dinge da drin sind. Man vertraut sich halt einfach im Wesentlichen. Das ist halt auch so ein wichtiger Punkt, dass man den Leuten, mit denen man halt in so einem Space insofern vertrauen möchte, dass, wenn die halt auch was für Geld machen, dass sie das dann halt auch einfach ehrlich sagen, dass es so ist, dass sie Geld damit verdienen gerade und halt eben entsprechend mehr in die Infrastruktur reintun, als jemand, der jetzt halt nur irgendwie sein Adventsgeschenk da bastelt. Aber eine weitere Parallelität zu diesem ganzen Open-Source-Ding ist eben nicht nur die Art des Arbeitens im Sinne von, unklar, ob es jetzt beruflich oder Freizeit oder ein Gemisch davon ist oder Freizeit, die zu Beruf wird oder Beruf, der gerade runtergescalt wird, auch Freizeit so, sondern dass auch dieser iterative Ansatz der Produktion von Software in den Hardware-Space reingeht. Also, dass man halt einfach Sachen ausprobiert, funktioniert nicht, nehmen wir das nächste.
Ja, wo ich sowieso schon so fleißig am CRE-Sendung erwähnt bin, muss ich auch nochmal auf eine Chaosradio International-Folge gehen mit dem bereits hier schon erwähnten Brie Pettis, der eine ganze Menge dazu beigetragen hat. Wie soll ich sagen, dieses Making Things zu popularisieren. Also irgendwie einfach immer wieder zu zeigen in seinem Video-Podcast, was man einfach so tun kann, sich verrücktes Zeug ausdenken und das dann eben dann auch zu dokumentieren. Dieses Dokumentieren ist ja auch Teil davon. Es geht ja gar nicht mehr so sehr nur darum, einen Ort zu haben, wo man was basteln kann, sondern es geht ja auch darum, was weiß ich, Anleitungen zu schaffen, FAQs zu erarbeiten, quasi auch Lehrmaterial dabei mitzuerzeugen.
Es funktioniert nicht ohne. Es ist halt genau wie bei Open-Source-Software, wo die nur funktioniert, weil sie dokumentiert ist und weil du halt reingucken kannst, funktioniert diese ganze Making-Bewegung eben genau darüber, dass es relativ viel Dokumentationen gibt, die Leute Blogs schreiben, gemeinsame Wikis schreiben und dergleichen Dinge, wo sie ihre Projekte dokumentieren. Und auf unterschiedlichen Graden von Nachbausicherheit, also von, ich sag mal, Projekten wie Arduino, die halt so dermaßen nachbausicher sind, dass einem schon mit Fürchten kommt, bis hin zu anderen Projekten, wo jemand nur mal schnell aufschreibt, hier so und so, wenn du irgendwie dieses Material so und so benutzt, dann irgendwie passieren diese interessanten Dinge. Dazwischen ist halt ein riesiges Spektrum. Aber das ist halt auch das Schöne daran, dass die meisten Leute auch das bestreben haben, anderen mitzuteilen, was sie gerade rausgefunden haben. Besonders wichtig ist zum Beispiel auch bei Maschinen. Wir sind gerade zum Beispiel dabei, zu überlegen, für die Raumfahrtagentur einen Laser-Cutter zu kaufen, einen kleinen. Es gibt halt Dutzende Chinasysteme am Markt. Die hat halt alle schon mal jemand gekauft, auseinandergenommen, angeguckt, überprüft, geguckt, was damit ist, wie der Software Support aussieht und was irgendwie die eigentlichen Probleme dabei sind. Das ermöglicht es einem, eine Menge Arbeit, Zeit und Geld zu sparen, weil andere Leute haben die Probleme schon mal gelöst oder rausgefunden, dass die Maschine so scheiße ist, dass man sie halt nicht haben will.
Ich wollte sagen, das ist ja auch ein Ausdruck von so einer Kultur, wie man mit Wissen und so umgeht. Das ist, glaube ich, auch eine Voraussetzung dafür gewesen, dass man durch das Internet und durch Open Source und Software auch einfach so gar nicht mehr in Frage stellt. Ich habe das jetzt hier gekauft, und dann rede ich darüber oder blogge ich darüber oder so. Weil das ist einfach auch auf jeden Fall wichtig. Aber das ist für die Leute, die sich damit befassen, auch irgendwie normal geworden. Da wundert sich dann keiner mehr, warum schreibt der denn darüber, dass er sich diese Nähmaschine gekauft hat? Weil es ist einfach so, und das ist ja fast schon verdächtig, wenn man über irgendwas nichts findet. Und irgendwie muss man natürlich auch gucken, vielleicht einfach altruistisch sagen, okay, dann versuche ich das auch zurückzugeben. Auch wenn ich nicht genau der Person, von dem ich Wissen bezogen habe, was zurückgebe, versuche ich auch meine eigenen Mitteilungen in diesen Pool zu geben. Man ist ja selber immer so froh, wenn man für irgendein Problem den Code schnipselt oder ein Beispiel oder jemanden gefunden hat, der schon mal was dazu gesagt hat. Ich weiß nicht, es ist ja normal, dass man auch einfach mal selber derjenige ist.
Ist das eigentlich eine Urban Legend, dass nach Musik die meistgetauschten Dateien im Internet Schnittmusterbögen sind? Und dass die Senioren da auch ganz fleißig den Fallsharing gewidmet haben?
Hab ich auch mal gehört.
Man findet erstaunlich viel, wenn man danach sucht. Es wurde einem nie in den Sinn gekommen, man musste sich nach den spezifischen Formaten suchen, indem die diese Schnittmusterbögen tauschen. Aber da gibt es halt wirklich viel. Wenn man mal danach sucht, dann fällt einem schon so schnell die Platte voll. Ist halt vom Volumen her nicht so viel. Die Dateien sind halt nicht so riesig, aber da passiert halt schon eine ganze Menge. Und es ist halt auch interessant, dass dadurch so ein gewisser Gap, der da halt natürlich immer da ist, gerade halt irgendwie zu älteren Generationen oder zu einfach Leuten, die nicht so mit Metall und so wollen, aber genau diese Methoden zu arbeiten, also Sachen zu teilen, zu modifizieren und so, das wird sich da auch repliziert und das wird halt so zum neuen Normalfall. Interessant ist halt auch, wenn man sich anguckt, die Basis von dem Ganzen ist ja schon, dass die Produktion von physischen Dingen, also von Halbzeugen, von Stoffen, von Elektronik, brutal billig geworden ist. Nimm mal z.B. die CNC-Fräse. Die Fräse, die wir uns gekauft haben, die hätte einfach vor 6 Jahren 10-fach höher gekostet. Und jetzt kommt sie halt aus China. In der Regel ist es halt so, dass die Software kann man nicht benutzen, die da mitgeliefert wird. Aber die Mechanik ist halbwegs okay. Und das ist halt so, bei dem Laser-Cut ist es wieder genau das selbe Ding. Die Software kannst du gleich direkt in die Tonne treten, die Elektronik kannst du eigentlich auch direkt replacen und dann halt deine eigene da dran hängen. Aber dann geht es halt. Das darf man doch nicht vergessen. Die ökonomische Basis des Ganzen ist halt, dass ein Großteil der physischen Produktion so billig geworden ist, dass ein iterativer Ansatz überhaupt möglich geworden ist. Was machst du damit? Man probiert eine Version, die funktioniert nicht. Recycle man entweder die Teile schmeißt oder schmeißt weg und macht es halt nochmal. Ist in der Regel vom materiellen Aufwand kein großer Schmerz mehr. Wenn du halt die Werkzeuge hast. Die Werkzeuge werden halt auch so billig, dass du halt z.B. CNC, was du jetzt mit dem digitalen Mischpult machst, ist halt genau das bei CNC. Du kannst es halt einfach replizieren, verändern, replizieren. Also ist halt so dieser Ansatz hin zum, naja, was wir eigentlich wollen, natürlich ein Replikator aus der Enterprise, wo du halt einfach nur noch ein 3D-Modell reinlädst und dann fällt es halt raus. So habe ich halt damit angefangen. Leider ist das halt nicht die Wahrheit. Also die Wahrheit ist halt, also ich glaube 2004, 2005, als ich da zum ersten Mal von dem Virus erfasst wurde, dachte ich, Herrgott, okay, gibt man 5000 Euro aus, dann kriegt man eine schöne Kiste, da ist eine USB-Schinstelle dran, stecke ich an meinen Mac und dann kommt da halt irgendwie schöne Hardware raus. Und stellt sich raus, ist halt natürlich die völlige Software-Hölle auf Erden. Und ist mitnichten so, dass es halt einfach mal so funktioniert. Und vom Replikator sind wir halt noch eine ganze Ecke weg. Aber der Grundansatz ist halt der, dass halt physische Dinge sich halt als Bits abbilden lassen und halt auch transformieren lassen wieder von Bits in physische Dinge.
Was mir eben noch einfällt, dass diese ganzen Produktionsmittel billiger geworden sind, ist natürlich auch ein zweischeidiges Ding, weil im Wesentlichen sagen wir jetzt ja hiermit, wir können jetzt hier endlich individuell produzieren, weil es so billig ist, weil es diese Massenproduktion von Werkzeugen oder Geräten gibt. Also wenn man das so weiterdenkt, dann sind es ja zwei komplett gegenseitige Geschichten. Nach dem Motto, wir können das jetzt billig kaufen und dann hacken, weil es halt billig produziert wurde, weil es halt ein Massenprodukt gibt. Das heißt, es ist ja eigentlich schon, vielleicht ist es auch subversiv, dass man halt individuelle Einzelstücke baut mit Sachen, die vom Fließband kommen.
Naja, am Ende ist es halt so, dass die Ausdifferenzierung, also was da vor einer Weile mal so als Stichwort Mars Customization unterwegs war, das funktioniert ja nur sehr begrenzt. Also wenn man sich so anguckt, so man kann zwar sein Auto in irgendwie drei Millionen Ausstellungsweiten kaufen und man kann sich sein Computer als Bill-to-Order zusammenstecken lassen. Also da erweitert sich schon das Spektrum, aber immer nur bei relativ wenigen Dingen. Ansonsten ist es halt so, dass ein Produkt schon eine sehr Self-Content-Unit ist, die man auch nicht so gut verändern kann, wenn man sie kauft, weil sonst kannst du sie halt nicht billigermaßen produzieren. Und genau diese Lücke zu sagen, wir können jetzt die Produktionsmittel selber haben, wir können die Materialien selber haben, wir können vor allem Wissen selber haben, die es uns ermöglichen, solche Sachen wirklich individuell zu bauen, das ist halt die interessante Neuentwicklung dabei.
Aber es wird vermutlich nie so kommen, dass die Weltwirtschaft irgendwann nur auf jeder Bauzeit selber wieder zurückschwingt. Weil es kostet ja trotzdem im Ende noch mehr, als wenn ich gesagt hätte, ich kaufe jetzt einfach den MP3-Player bei was weiß ich, im Internet. Oder ich baue mir den selber, der so ein bisschen was anderes kann, dann kostet mich das das Fünffache, weil die Materialien teurer sind, trotz auch wenn sie billig sind.
Der Kerngrund dabei ist einfach, dass Arbeitskraft nicht mehr wirklich viel Geld kostet. Also gerade wenn wir uns jetzt China und Asien und Indien und so angucken, ist der Anteil an Arbeitskraft und das ist ja das, was du durchs Selbermachen dazu bringst, an so einem Endprodukt ist relativ gering. Und der beruhigt natürlich die Preise klar. Also wenn du halt viel Handarbeit, viel stupide Handarbeit, was sich löten oder zusammenschrauben oder so ersetzen kannst, macht zwar das Endprodukt in der Massenproduktion billiger, aber der Anteil für dich, den du dazu tun kannst, umgerechnet wie du auf Euro, also mit deinem Stundensatz hier, ist dein MP3-Player immer teurer, selbst wenn du nur drei Schrauben reindrehst, als wenn das in China passiert für irgendwie einen Euro die Stunde oder einen Euro pro Tag oder so. Und eigentlich geht es halt wirklich um das Selbermachen. Also das Ziel wird erstmal für eine Weile nicht sein, dass es billiger wird oder so, sondern dass man Sachen intelligenter macht, also Sachen selber machen kann, die vorher nicht gingen.
Ich denke, es geht wirklich auch ums Selber. Also es ist wirklich ein Erfahrungsding eigentlich. Also einerseits natürlich der Lernespekt und dann natürlich auch, na ja, Spaß am Gerät. Sozusagen einfach Gewinn an Lebensqualität durch die Erfahrung einfach nicht unbedingt auch immer so abhängig zu sein von anderen und nur so als End-Consumer in der Produktwelt zu leben, sondern vielleicht auch selber da aktiv einzugreifen.
Ja, und es gibt halt eine ganze Menge Sachen, die kriegst du einfach nicht. Also die schränken dich, also du wirst einfach durch die Verfügbarkeit oder Nicht-Verfügbarkeit von spezifischen Produkten eingeschränkt. Also insbesondere, wenn man sich relativ weit vorne in einem Zyklus bewegt von Produktnutzung, nehmen wir zum Beispiel mal Elektro-Fahrräder. Da ist es so, dass bisher war die Tatsache, dass es in der Fahrradwelt praktisch keine Standards gibt, sondern alle nur Hersteller-Standards sind, war nicht weiter tragisch. Weil du hast halt dein Fahrrad gekauft und wenn dann irgendwas kaputt daran war, dann bist du halt zu dem Verkäufer gehören und hast dir halt das Ersatzteil geholt. Jetzt ist es so, durch den Einbau von diesen Elektromotoren in die Fahrräder entsteht der Zwang zu einer gewissen Standardisierung, der aber von den Herstellern noch nicht beachtet wird. Man muss das halt irgendwie da reinkriegen. Die Motoren haben eine bestimmte Größe, die Bremsen müssen irgendwohin. Nur wenn man in der Lage ist, sich die Teile selber zu machen, die man dafür braucht, um in dein Fahrrad, was du eigentlich gerne elektrifizieren möchtest, einzubauen, nur dann bist du in der Lage, daraus wieder was zu machen, was du auch gerne benutzen willst. Und was nicht nur so ein endloses Gefrickel mit Kabelbindern hier und Rangelgaffert da ist.
Ich glaube, es ist doch ganz wichtig, dass man auch sieht, dass das selber machen nicht unbedingt heißt, dass es dann irgendwie so was Halbfertiges am Ende immer sein muss. Sondern dass man auch einfach durch die Methoden und durch das Wissen, dass man hat, tatsächlich auch gut aussehende, funktionale, hübsche Dinge und so erzeugen kann. Weil ich glaube, das hat immer noch sehr viel von diesem Frickel und so und so. Nimm bewusst das und sag mal, denn hält das jetzt halt, wenn ich das hier festklebe und fertig, das muss ja gar nicht.
Auch schöne Sachen sollen sozusagen dabei rauskommen.
Und man lernt eine ganze Menge über Engineering. Weil, etwa bei Software machen, nämlich Lernen durch Reverse-Engineering oder ein anderes Hausgutgucken, falls wir den haben, tut man natürlich auch bei Hardware. Also diese auseinanderschrauben und gucken, was drin ist, erweitert sich natürlich immer mehr dahin, wie haben sie dann eigentlich diese Kohäuse gemacht, wie hängen die dann da ihre Schrauben rein, welche Tricks haben sie dann gemacht, um das Ding billig zu machen, also um die Anzahl der Chips zu reduzieren, und dergleichen Dinge mehr. Also diese Wissen darüber, was wirklich in so einem Ding drin ist, ist eine integrale Grundvoraussetzung dafür, selber Sachen zu machen. Also dass man den State of the Art durch aufschrauben lernt, ist halt bei Software wie bei Hardware so.
Was ist denn jetzt eigentlich der Grund dafür, dass das jetzt gerade erst so aufkommt? Warum haben wir das nicht schon seit 10, 20 Jahren? Was beflügelt denn diesen ganzen Do-it-yourself-Trend so? Liegt das nur daran, dass so ein paar Leute mal aufgestanden sind und angefangen haben, oder gibt es auch andere Gründe?
Es gibt mehrere, wir können uns vielleicht darüber streiten. Einer ist, glaube ich, auf jeden Fall das Internet und auch damit verbunden die Art und Weise, wie man mit Wissen umgeht. Also auch die Tatsache, dass es einfach normal geworden ist, Dinge online zu stellen, darüber zu reden, dass man sozusagen nicht mehr auf irgendwelche Blätter von irgendwelchen Herstellern angewiesen ist und dass sich da einfach Konventionen in Sachen Software und Wissen entwickelt haben, die man jetzt auch einmal auf Produktion, Hardware und andere Dinge bringen kann.
Und dass sich der Standard, was normal ist an Dokumentation, also die Erwartungshaltung von allen auch dahingehend erweitert hat, dass man einfach Produkte, wo man das Handbuch nicht runterladen kann, kauft man halt nicht. Und Chips, wo die Datenblätter nicht frei verfügbar sind, die kauft man halt nicht. Und bis hin dazu Hardware, die halt keine Lendungstreiber mit dazu hat, die wird halt weniger verkauft. Und das ist halt so ein Ding, wo man sich die Realität durch Erwartungshaltung von vielen ändert. Also das ist halt einfach die Normalität. Also genau das, was ich halt immer sage, wir müssen nicht die Mehrheit sein, wir müssen nur das ändern, was normal ist. Und das ist das, was da passiert. Also das ist halt einfach der Anspruch, den die meisten Leute daran haben. Wenn sie ein normales Produkt kaufen, ist es sehr viel geringer als den Leute, wie wir haben. Also er sagt, wir wollen halt gerne genau wissen, was da drin passiert, wir wollen präzise wissen, wie es funktioniert, damit wir es optimal benutzen können, verändern können, nachbauen können, was auch immer. Nur wir sind halt die laute Minderheit. Wir sind diejenigen, die im Zweifel auch sagen, hey Hersteller, rück mal das Datenblatt raus. So und naja, und die anderen halten halt den Mund, also rück der Hersteller irgendwann das Datenblatt raus.
Aber es ist ja nicht nur in dem Hardware- und Hacking-Bereich. Es geht ja auch in Sachen Handwerk und so, wo man jedenfalls das Gefühl hat, vielleicht wird es ja auch nur hergeschrieben, dass da mit Plattformen, wo Leute halt auf einmal ganz selbstgemachtes verkaufen und Leute, die noch sagen, das hätte ich gern. Also das muss ja noch irgendwie einen weiteren Grund haben, finde ich.
So die kleinen Handwerks, so Einzelkämpfer, die einfach so Einzelstücke machen und jetzt die Möglichkeit haben, übers Internet das zu verkaufen.
Auch so eine Longtail-Geschichte vielleicht.
Ja, ist das auf jeden Fall. Ich hab da so ein bisschen Zweifel bei diesen kommerziellen Making-Resale-Plattformen, weil das meiste, was man da auf finden kann, sind relativ wenige sehr nützliche Sachen. Das meiste sind halt irgendwie Accessoires, Schmuck, ein bisschen Möbel, so Sachen, die halt ein relativ, so ein Individualisierungszubehör sind in dem Sinne. Und in dem Augenblick, wo es eine wirklich gute Idee ist, wo man halt daraus ein Produkt wieder machen könnte, z.B. ein Chumby oder so was.
Ein was?
Ein Chumby. Das ist halt so ein völlig sinnloses, aber knutliges Elektronikgerät. Hat WLAN-Display und eine knutlige Hülle. Da kann man Software drauf tun. Da kann man halt als Wecker benutzen oder als Anzeige für Börsenkurse. Man kann es knuddeln. Man kann es knuddeln. Genau. Das wird dann halt auch wieder ein Produkt. Dann wird halt genau wieder dieser Sprung von dem Einzelhandwerker zu einem Mikro-Startup. Der passiert dann halt auch sehr fließend. Das geht dann auch sehr schnell. Ob denn so diese ganzen Making-Shops da auf Dauer funktionieren, weiß ich nicht. Ich meine, hier der Wander und so, keine Ahnung, ob das tut.
Ich frage mich auch, ich lasse mich da manchmal auch gern verführen. Ich hab dann auch natürlich so ein Gefühl, wenn ich irgendein einfaches Objekt des Lebens, ein T-Shirt oder so kaufe, gibt es mir manchmal auch ein besseres Gefühl, das halt irgendwie jemandem zu bezahlen, den ich auch als Person vielleicht nicht persönlich kenne, aber wo ich sehe, okay, diese Person hat das gemacht und es ist nicht von der Stange und davon gibt es eine Million andere. Das fühlt sich manchmal auch ganz gut an. Ich frage mich aber jetzt halt nur, ob das noch irgendwas mehr kann, diese ganzen Plattformen und diese Bewegungen. Also kommen da wirklich Sachen raus, die was anderes sind als Accessoires und Kunst? Das ist auch eine zentrale Frage, wo ich denn viel drüber nachdenken muss. Als mich jemand gefragt hat, dann haben wir all diese Produktionsmittel und wir wissen, wie das geht und wir können das machen. Was kommt denn dabei Konkretes raus, was wirklich jemand braucht?
Wo endet denn bei dir Accessoire?
Das war jetzt halt...
Wenn du halt durch diese typischen Make-Shops klickst, ist halt z.B. der Wanderbestieg zu 90% aus Strickware.
Na gut, ich meine, das ist ja dann auch Kleidung. Größeren Nutzen hat man ja von fast... Also das benutzen wir nur wirklich alle täglich, die ganze Zeit permanent. So wie die Bedeutung von Kleidung nochmal.
Also, ich meine, gut haschen. Kleidung, also ich sag mal Textil, Textilbearbeitung ist natürlich traditionell schon immer der weitaus größte Bereich von allem Hobby und Making gewesen. Und ist halt auch immer noch so. Und...
Die Strickrevolution.
Genau, die Strickrevolution. Ist halt so, weil es halt einfach immer schon immer so war, dass die Menschen Bedürfnisse nach individueller Kleidung hatten und im Laden nicht gefunden haben, was sie wollten oder abgeändert haben und dergleichen Dinge mehr. Und es ist halt auch relativ einfach, weil die Werkzeuge sind halt immer verfügbar gewesen. Nähdelaar ist immer verfügbar gewesen. Nähmaschinen sind schon seit vielen Dutzend Jahren billig. Das heißt also, man kann es halt einfach machen. Der Aufwand ist halt groß und ist halt auch nicht reproduzierbar. Und das ist, glaube ich, genau der Kernpunkt dabei. Diese Idee, dass du, wenn du ein Produkt hast, was du zum Beispiel mit einem RepRap oder einer CNC-Fräse produzieren kannst und du es halt dann fertig entwickelt hast, dass du es einfach replizieren kannst und dann auf physische Art und Weise an deiner intellektuellen Leistung durch Replikation verdienen kannst. Das ist, glaube ich, der eigentliche Knackpunkt hinter diesen ganzen Make-Shops.
Was ich noch wichtig finde oder ich glaube, es liegt auch daran, dass in den Köpfen der meisten Leute klar ist, irgendwie Kleidung, die kann ich im Laden kaufen, die kann ich aber auch selber machen, weil ich rudimentär oder dadurch, dass ich es mir aneignen kann, dass das Reverse-Engineering von einem T-Shirt kann man sehr gut nachvollziehen. Aber inzwischen sind wir in einer Welt, wo es halt viele andere tolle Tools und Objekte gibt. Und für viele Leute ist dann so nach Mod und T-Shirt, das verstehe ich, das kann ich dir auch vielleicht nicht gut, aber mit Übung selber nähen. Aber jetzt hier mein iPhone oder so, das ist irgendwie schwarze Magie, das kann ich nicht verstehen. Und das ist halt so ein bisschen auch der Antrieb, dass man sagt, ja, aber kann man ja doch. Also es ist ja gar nicht so, dass denn irgendwo das Verständnis aufhört, weil vielleicht sozusagen das, was drinsteckt, schwieriger ist. Und dass man einfach sagt, inzwischen ist das Maß der Dinge für do it yourself nicht mehr, bau dir dein Hochbett oder wechsel deinen Fahrradreifen, sondern die Dinge des täglichen Lebens sind eben nicht nur Fahrräder und T-Shirts, sondern seit den letzten 20, 30 Jahren sind viele Sachen dazugekommen. Und die müssen wir jetzt auch mal aufmachen. Und viele Leute wissen dann einfach noch gar nicht, dass es geht. Das ist natürlich so ein klassisches Hackerding, aber ich mag, dass man mit Sachen wie vielleicht dem Arduino, den wir eben schon erwähnt haben, sowas auch reintragen kann bei Leuten, die einfach gedacht haben, mein do-it-yourself-Fähigkeiten, die hören auf, weiß was ich, bei Kleidung, bei Möbeln. Und dann alles danach können nur noch große Firmen machen. Und das Wissen, dass man natürlich auch solche Dinge selber machen kann und dass es darüber geredet wird, dass Leute einem da helfen können, das finde ich echt sehr wichtig.
Kommen wir doch mal langsam so in den Bereich von, was es denn nun wirklich konkret an neuen Werkzeugen gibt. Ihr habt jetzt schon mehrfach erwähnt, so jetzt kann man halt Dinge tun, die man vorher nicht tun konnte. Das ist einerseits natürlich dem Internet geschuldet, andererseits aber jetzt auch der Verfügbarkeit von konkreten Produktionsmitteln, mit denen man jetzt erstmal anfangen kann, die es jetzt vor einiger Zeit nicht gab. Sind dir aber schon ein paar Sachen gefallen, ich weiß nicht so recht, womit man da am besten einsteigt. Reprap heißt was?
Also die Idee hinter dem Reprap ist, dass man Plaste drucken kann. Also dass man in der Lage ist...
Also wofür steht denn Reprap? Replication?
Rapid Replicator.
Klang besser so rum, ja?
Genau. Und die Idee dahinter ist folgende. Wenn man Plaste schmilzt und durch eine kleine dünne Düse presst, sodass dann ein super dünner geschmolzener Plastefaden entsteht. Und dann diesen Kopf, aus dem diese flüssige Plaste in dem Faden rauskommt, auf einem XY-Tisch hin und her fährt und den auch noch absenken kann, dann kann man sich Gegenstände aus Plaste ausdrucken. Weil der geschmolzene Plastefaden klebt sich wiederum auf den anderen, den Plastefaden, der schon da ist. Und bisher waren solche Plasteprinter halt so mehrere 10.000 Euro Objekte. Die können dann halt auch tolle Sachen, wie zum Beispiel mehrere Materialien gleichzeitig ausdrucken. Und da gibt es so aus den modernsten dieser Drucker fallen halt auch Teile, die man tatsächlich schon direkt benutzen kann. Und die Idee hinter dem RepRap war zu sagen, das können wir auch, aber wir können es für ein paar Hundert Dollar.
Also die Geräte gibt es ja schon seit längerer Zeit in der Industrie. Wir hatten glaube ich vor genau vor 10 Jahren auf dem ersten Camp hatten wir schon so eine Maschine stehen, die da irgendwie fleißig Raketen ausgedruckt hat. Genau. Aber das war halt alles noch so ein bisschen im nicht ganz so affordable Bereich.
Genau.
Ich weiß nicht genau, was es dir gekostet hat. Ja, wahrscheinlich. Und jetzt gibt es so kleine Geräte, die so Mikrocontroller gesteuert im Prinzip denselben Kram machen, wenn vielleicht auch nicht mit derselben Präzision.
Präzision ist das eine, das andere ist, wenn man Plaste druckt, kann man halt nicht über Luft drucken. Also du brauchst halt immer irgendwas, was da drunter ist. Also du kannst zum Beispiel...
Keine Löcher machen sozusagen?
Nee, keine Bögen, also keine... Du kannst keine Brücken bauen.
Oder Modelle, wo denn irgendwo auf halber Höhe eine neue Ebene anfängt.
Genau, so eine Sachen sind halt schwierig. Da muss man sich halt was überlegen, dass man noch so Stützkonstruktion rein macht. Und bei den kommerziellen Plaste-Printern, die haben die neueren Modelle noch ein zweites Material, so eine wachsartige Substanz, die zusätzlich dazu gedruckt werden kann. Das heißt also, da werden halt, wird halt in dem oder um das zu stützende Plaste-Objekt, wird nochmal aus diesem Wachs eine Stützkonstruktion gedruckt, auf die dann die Plaste gespritzt wird.
Das heißt, eigentlich wird alles gefüllt, aber nur entweder mit dem einen oder mit anderen Materialen. Der Rest wird dann einfach rausgespürt.
Rausgespült.
Rausgespült, okay.
Und das wäre jetzt halt so der nächste Schritt, der vermutlich auch irgendwann kommen wird. Momentan ist diese Retro-Konstruktion halt erstaunlich primitiv. Also das ist halt eigentlich nichts weiter als ein Stück Messing mit einem Rohr. Das wird erhitzt mit einer Heizwendel. Vorne ist ein kleines Loch drin. Und dann wird einfach ein Dünner-Plastostab, so 3-4 mm.
Also im Prinzip ist das eine ferngesteuerte Heißklebepistole.
Ja, präzise. Wird halt einfach durchgepresst. Es ist halt wirklich nichts weiter als eine Heißklebepistole für ABS.
Und ferngesteuert sozusagen dreidimensional. Das heißt, einerseits X, Y und dann ist das Ganze noch auf so einer Platte, die dann hoch und runter fahren kann. Okay, dann baut man sozusagen von unten nach oben.
Genau. Das ist halt so das Basisprinzip des Ganzen.
Ist das das einzige Konzept, was so im Hobbybereich derzeit gemacht wird? Weil es gibt ja in der Industrie jetzt auch noch so laserbasierte Sachen, die in so eine Flüssigkeit reinschießen, die dann da härtet. Die haben ja auch ganz andere...
Laser-Sintern ist...
Sintern heißt das.
Genau, da kann man mittlerweile sogar Metalle mitmachen. Da kannst du Metallpulver mit zusammenschmelzen. Da sind wir halt noch nicht. Also es ist halt schon eine richtige Anackung, dass der...
Fehlt noch.
Also der Selber-Machen-Bereich, einfach durch die Kostenbeschränkungen, die wir haben, repliziert natürlich Sachen, die es in der Repel-Prototyping-Industrie schon lange gibt. Und da ist es aber so, dass diese Repel-Prototyping-Industrie hat halt andere Anforderungen. Die hat gezeigt, dass es geht, dass man individuelle Sachen machen kann. Also zum Beispiel, als ich das zum ersten Mal gesehen habe, habe ich es nicht geglaubt, da war ich bei einem Automobilhersteller in einer Prototypenfabrik. Und die hatten da so eine Sechs-Achsen-CNC-Fräse und haben da innerhalb von vier Stunden einen kompletten Motorblock aus einem Stück gefräst. Aus Alu? Ja, aus Alu. So ein fetter, großer Motorblock. Und das ist halt so ein Kopf, der sich nicht nur nach oben und unten bewegen kann, sondern auch noch drehen und wenden kann, sodass du halt auch innen unten in Sachen reinfräsen kannst. Und damit kannst du halt nahezu beliebig komplexe Teile fräsen. Die fräsen dann mit einer brutalen Geschwindigkeit durch dieses Alu durch. Du siehst eigentlich fast nichts, weil da nur noch das Kühlmittel spritzt. Und wenn du das einmal gesehen hast, dann glaubst du eigentlich, geht alles.
Da kommt ein funktionierender Motorball raus. So jetzt so Industry-Grade, den man so ein Auto reinbauen kann, und dann fährt das drei Jahre damit?
Nee, das ist halt so ein Prototyp. Also das ist halt so für irgendwie mal ein Design von einem Motor ausprobieren, der dann halt für ein Vierteljahr auf dem Teststand läuft oder so.
Aber solange halten die dann schon durch?
Genau.
Ist jetzt nicht so ein Teil, was dann nach 20 Minuten wegglüht oder so?
Nee. Also das ist halt so der, also wie gesagt in der Industrie kann man, wenn man halt richtig Geld ausgibt, mit den Maschinen, die man heute hat, kann man Sachen machen, die wirklich benutzbar sind. Also zum Beispiel die NASA bastelt gerade für die ISS an einem System, wo sie mit einem Laser einen Metallfaden schmelzen.
Also für die Traumstation.
Für oben auf der ISS, wo sie Teile machen wollen, die wie geschmiedeter Stahl sind von der Benutzbarkeit her. Also das ist halt so der Ziel, an dem die da gerade arbeiten. Um genau das Problem zu lösen, dass Zeug da hochschiffen ist halt maus teuer und dauert halt manchmal einfach zu lange, wenn ihnen gerade wieder mal der Shuttle kaputt gegangen ist und denen da oben fehlt halt irgendwie der wichtige Bolzen, der sie irgendwie vom Vakuum trennt, dann wollen sie den halt lieber nur das 3D-Fall hochschicken. Das kann ich schon verstehen.
Und dann bauen sie sich sozusagen die Teile selber vor Ort mit dem Vor-Ort-Laser.
Genau. Also das ist halt so ein Ding, das...
Bisschen, dass die ganze Raumstation sich da selber ausbaut. Schickt da eigentlich nur noch so Stahlblöcke hoch und dann...
Das geht ja dann in die Richtung, dass in dem Moment, wenn auch diese Replikatur-Maschinen intelligent werden, dass wir denn vermutlich ein Problem bekommen.
Aber jetzt sind wir schon bei Terminator, oder was?
Bisschen hin ist es nicht.
Das ist natürlich unsere Endabsicht. Also wir sind halt aus der Zukunft gesponsert.
Ja, ich glaube, vorher werden wir einen ordentlichen Make-Line haben.
Ich sehe jetzt aus diesen Monolithen aus 2001 auf einmal mit einem ganz anderen Licht. Das ist im Prinzip nichts anderes als Rohmaterial, das Teil.
Also man sieht, dieser ganze Reppe-Prototyping-Ansatz ist halt schon älter. Nur jetzt kommt er halt in den Bereich, das wir halt selber machen können. Und genau dieser Ansatz, diese Iteration, also dass man halt einfach hingeht und sagt, wir haben hier ein Modell, das rendern wir jetzt mal in die Realität mit Hilfe unserer Maschinen, probieren es aus. Und wenn es nicht funktioniert, dann gucken wir, was nicht funktioniert, modifizieren das Modell und lassen uns die nächste Version raus. Also das ist halt so dieser Ansatz, der vorher nur mit extrem hohem Aufwand war, wenn du halt jeden Bolzen, jede Schraube, jedes irgendwas an so einem Ding per Hand auf einer Drehmaschine von irgendjemanden machen lassen musst, der auch noch die richtige Erfahrung hat dafür. Das ist so ein Entwicklungsaufwand halt brutal hoch. So in der Autonustrie zum Beispiel ist eigentlich nur noch Rapid Prototyping. Also die lassen sich halt die Teile aus ihren Maschinen raus, bauen die Karre einmal zusammen, probieren sie aus, tauschen was nicht geht und entwickeln dann wiederum aus den Modellen, die sie fürs Rapid Prototyping haben, die Formen zum Beispiel fürs Blech biegen oder so eine Sache. Die werden dann wiederum nur in solider ausgebaut, um halt Massenproduktion machen zu können. Und die Chinesen zum Beispiel machen es umgekehrt. Die nehmen halt so ein Teil, machen ein 3D-Modell da draußen, bauen es nach. Also das ist halt so ein, dass man halt Geräte mittlerweile so brutal schnell, zum Beispiel die iPhone-Clones, die es da unten gibt, die gibt es halt deswegen, weil es halt schnell geht. Du kannst halt so ein 3D-Modell, kannst halt in ein paar Tagen zusammenkloppen davon. Dann lässt du dir halt den Formteil da raus aus deiner Fräse und dann pressst du halt die Ober- und Unter-Schalen, die du brauchst.
Wobei die wahrscheinlich einfach nur das iPhone auseinandergenommen haben und da gescannt haben, oder?
Du machst ein 3D-Modell. Scannen reicht nicht alleine. Die Scannen erzeugt dir nur eine Rohform, die du nachbearbeiten musst. Das ist ungefähr so, wie Nachvektorisieren von Fotos. So, also es geht halt zum Teil automatisch, aber du hast halt eine Rohform vom Modell, aber du musst es halt glätten und irgendwie daraus... Und naja, da kommen wir halt schon zum nächsten Problempunkt. Wenn man sich so den Prozess anguckt, wie man aus einem 3D-Modell ein physisches Objekt macht, dann können wir zum Beispiel RepRap als Beispiel wieder nehmen, dann hast du jetzt nebenan, nimmst du das Beispiel, du willst dir eine Tasse drucken. Also du hast halt ein 3D-Modell von einer Tasse, die hast du halt modelliert. Man möchte jetzt aber, dass der RepRap die ausdruckt. Dann musst du dem RepRap ja irgendwie sagen, was er tun soll. Und das ist die sogenannte Tool-Pass-Generierung, also die Generierung eines Ablaufes für den RepRap, dass er weiß, wo er jetzt langfahren muss. Und das ist halt tatsächlich ein Software-Problem. Und zwar ein richtiges Software-Problem.
Reihenfolge und so weiter. Womit fängt man an?
Überhaupt, dass es Software gibt, die das zuverlässig tut und so. Also da ist noch einiges zu tun, habe ich so den Eindruck.
Also ihr nickt jetzt so ein bisschen mit dem Blick des Erfahrenen. Mit welchen Geräten habt ihr denn schon gearbeitet? Also RepRap ist ja nur ein Projekt.
Genau. Also wir haben halt bei unserer Raumfahrtagentur sehr viel Zeit damit verbracht, unsere Fräse ans Laufen zu bekommen. Wir haben uns halt so eine China-Fräse gekauft. Im Wesentlichen sind das halt alles nur Stepper-Motoren. Also du hast halt einen Stepper, den musst du irgendwie ansteuern und dann hast du dein Wirkgerät, also entweder ein Fräserkopf, der sich dreht oder eine Düse aus der Plaste rauskommt. Das ist also so vom Prinzip her ist das alles sehr simpel. Du brauchst halt irgendwie deine drei Stepper-Motoren oder vier und musst die irgendwie ansteuern. Aber das Problem ist halt genau diese Generierung dieser Ansteuer-Folge. Und zu meinem großen Ersetzen festgestellt habe, ist, dass sich da seit den 80er Jahren so an dem Grundliegenden hat sich da nichts getan. Zum Beispiel für so eine Fräse generieren alle Programme hinten raus etwas, was sich G-Code nennt. Das ist so ein ASCII, wo man noch so den Lochstreifen durchscheinen sieht. Also das ist halt so ein G-Code. Das ist halt so eine Folge von ASCII-Commandos, die jetzt Axel X auf diese Position fahren, Axel Z auf diese Position fahren mit der Geschwindigkeit. Also einfach nur so hintereinander weg. Das sind so Kommandos da drin, da siehst du förmlich, dass die mal dafür gemacht waren, dass deine Maschine den Lochstreifen hin und her gefahren hat.
Also noch älter als HPGL-Plotter-Technologie.
Und das ist das, was hinten rauskommt. Und diesen G-Code, den tut man in die Maschinensteuerung. Wir benutzen eigentlich mittlerweile nur noch Linux-CNC, also EMC2.
Was ist das Software?
Das ist eine Software, die nichts weiter tut, als genau diese Stepper-Steuerung zu machen und dir auf dem Bildschirm anzuzeigen, wo ist jetzt dein Werkstück. Also wo vermutet ihr, dass dein Werkstück ist? So sieht der der Fahrt aus, den er jetzt fahren würde, auf dem Werkstück und wo er gerade ist. Dann hast du tausend Möglichkeiten zum Steuern, noch Sensoren anbauen und dergleichen Dinge mehr. Aber bis du dahin kommst, musst du erst mal diese Toolpass-Generierung machen. Da haben wir sehr lange gefrickelt. Es gibt ja tausend profitäre Windows-Tools, zwischen 29 Dollar Shareware bis 10.000 Euro Kommerz wäre. Und richtig taugend tun die halt alle nix. Das ist halt alles speziell für einen speziellen Anwendungsfall angepasst. Jedes Stück Software lohnt es mir als erstes zu gucken, was hat denn der Typ, der es geschrieben hat, ursprünglich machen gewollt? Und ist das, was du machen willst, irgendwie kompatibel mit dem, was der damals wollte?
Wie muss ich mir denn deine Fräse vorstellen? Ist das jetzt keine Drehbank, sondern ist das schon so ein Bohrer, der von oben kommt?
Genau, das ist halt so ein Motor, da steckt unten so ein Fräskopf dran und da drunter ist ein Kreuztisch, also ein XY-Tisch, der von Stepper-Motoren bewegt wird.
Womit man das Material einspannt und dann wird das Werkstück bewegt.
Genau, das Werkstück wirkt auf diesem XY-Tisch bewegt und der Fräskopf geht halt hoch und runter. Genau, das ist es de facto.
Das heißt, man kann so Löcher machen, man kann was durchbohren, man kann...
Man kann auch seitlich fräsen. Ein Fräser hat ja den Vorteil, dass er an der Seite schneidet, nicht nur von oben nach unten.
Das heißt, dieser Kopf kann sich um das Werkstück herum drehen?
Das wäre dann eine Vierachsfräse. Also wir haben nur drei Achsen.
Ach so, okay.
Also man muss es dann anders einspannen. Genau, er kann sich aber seitlich ran bewegen, er kann sich nicht nur von oben nach unten bewegen, sondern auch seitlich ins Werkstück rein.
Um so eine Nut zu machen.
Genau, oder einen Legostein zu bauen oder dergleichen Dinge. Das ist auch der typische Anwendungsfall, den die allermeisten Leute, wenn sie so hartwegs ihre Software im Griff haben, machen sie erst mal einen Legostein.
Aus Metall.
Oder was auch immer ihr Material gerade hergibt. Wir haben es aus Plastik gemacht. Der Grund ist einfach, da kannst du deine Präzision testen. Da lernst du zu schätzen, was die da eigentlich tun bei Lego. Dass sie in der Lage sind, so brutale Mengen Legosteine in dieser unglaublichen Präzision rauszuhauen. Das wurde mir da auch erst mal klar, als ich versucht habe einen nachzubauen.
Das Lego beeindruckt vor allem, wenn man mal die China-Klons in der Hand hat, und man sich immer fragt, wie die überhaupt diese Frechheit besitzen können, sowas zu verkaufen, weil es einfach nicht hält. Also dieses Knarzen. Das ist übrigens dieses Lego-Knarzen, finde ich ja auch, eine der tollsten Feedback-Signale, die man eigentlich so erhalten kann. Dieses Wissen passt, es hat wirklich genau diesen Punkt erreicht. Das ist ja eigentlich auch das, worauf man bei dieser Bauerei hinaus will.
Also um nochmal an diese G-Code-Geschichte anzuknüpfen, wir haben da bei uns jetzt seit einiger Zeit so ein Makerboard rumzustehen.
Bei uns ist jetzt wo?
Bei uns ist sozusagen im Baustellen-Kontext, es gibt einen Coworking-Ort in Neukölln, da heißt Studio 70, wo im Wesentlichen Leute an ihren Schreibtischen sitzen, wir aber auch dankenswerterweise von unseren Vermieter Reinhard hinten eine fertig eingerichtete Werkstatt haben, die wir so langsam übernehmen. Und nach irgendeinem Webmontag hier in Berlin am Anfang des Jahres, sagte ich zu den Leuten, die mir zufällig gegenüber sassen, wir kaufen uns jetzt vielleicht mal so ein Makerboard, also diese von Brie Pettis und so weiter Makerboard Industries in New York hergestellte Open Source 3D-Druckergeschichte, die sehr weit auf dem Raprap basiert, aber halt ein anderes Gehäuse hat im Wesentlichen. Und dann sagten diese Leute, die mir gegenüber sassen, klingt auch toll, da gebe ich auch was dazu und dann wurde das irgendwie so gemeinschaftlich gekauft, so spontan. Kostenpunkt? Das hat jetzt ungefähr 750 Dollar plus Steuern und Versand, dann kam das glaube ich auf ungefähr 750 Euro oder 800 Euro so raus. Was ich sagen wollte, auch das funktioniert mit diversen Open Source-Tools, die auch dankenswerterweise sehr oft abgegradet werden, aber man sieht, bei jedem Upgrade kommt halt so viel rein, wo du denkst, oh, das ging vorher alles nicht. Da wird also nachgeliefert im Wesentlichen. Das ist ein tolles Hardware-Projekt und man freut sich immer schon darauf, was man dann irgendwann damit machen kann, wenn die Software dann auch mal hinterherkommt, wenn man wie ich zum Beispiel nicht persönlich in der Lage ist, die richtig aktiv weiterzuentwickeln, außer vielleicht Bug-Reports oder so einzureichen. Und auch da wird halt dieser G-Code erzeugt, wo ich dann auch erst mal dachte, oh, das sieht ja sehr un-, also das sind riesen Dateien, die sehr, sehr, wie soll man sagen, also... Jaja, da steht dann halt so G220X5 und also es sind einfach nur so archaische Befehle und dann, ja, dann wird das da reingetan und dann macht das Ding oft auch einfach scheiße, also das ist so eine Sache, die noch gar nicht so ist im Sinne von ich habe hier das glänzende Kästchen und drücke auf den magischen Knopf, sondern...
Was nehmt ihr da zum Steuern?
Wir haben bisher diese mitgelieferte Replicator G Software genommen.
Ja, also wie gesagt, wir sind mittlerweile an dem Punkt, dass wir, also wir haben an die Fräse auch noch ein Rapperappet herangebaut, weil wir hatten schon mal den XY-Tisch, muss man nicht nochmal einen neuen nehmen, und haben halt einfach an die Seite da so ein...
Also anstatt eines Bohrers quasi eine Heißlebe-Pistole herangebaut?
Da neben, genau. Ja, also so da neben rangehängt.
Ah, okay.
Also fährt halt genauso mit und und fährt halt mit dem Linux-CNC auch. Und das ist eine deutliche Verbesserung, weil das wird halt auch von Leuten benutzt in der Industrie, die damit irgendwie so Hallen große Fräsen fahren. Und das ist halt so...
Also jetzt von der Präzision des Stepper-Motors her, oder?
Die Software schmerzt halt nicht. Also das ist halt ausnahmsweise...
Die Linux-CNC...
Linux-CNC, EMC 2 heißt die, genau.
EMC 2.
Genau, die ist halt dringend eine Empfehlung, wenn man halt in dem Bereich Maschinen steuert, das ist momentan wirklich so das, was am wenigsten wehtut.
Und dann jetzt im Prinzip alle auf diesem G-Code aufbauen, ist das auch alles austauschbar?
Das ist die Theorie.
Die Theorie, ja. Ich dachte mir schon, das ist nicht genau. Man braucht noch einen Druckertreiber da drunter.
Naja, also ich meine, so eine Fräse, wenn wir beim Drucker sind, so eine Fräse bzw. so ein RepRap ist halt wie ein Drucker, der keine Ahnung davon hat, wie groß das Papier ist, wo das Papier ist, welche Tinte er nimmt und ob es überhaupt eingespannt ist. Und damit versuchst du dann zu drucken.
Es ist auch gerade kürzlich bei Makerboard auf dem Blog angekündigt, sie wollen jetzt langsam in die Richtung auch weiterarbeiten, dass die Maschine überhaupt weiß, wo sie ist, wer sie ist, was sie da tut, weil im Moment schickt die Software dem Stepper-Motor, hier fahr mal so und so hoch. Und dann hofft man, dass er das auch einfach gemacht hat. Und auch dieses Prinzip wieder mit...
Hat er weiß nicht, wo er ist?
Im Moment noch nicht.
Das ist dann so wie früher bei der C64-Floppy, dass er dann erstmal den Kopf nach hinten anschlagen muss. Ratat und dann...
Genau. Das tut er halt im Oberteil auch nicht.
Telegram-Entwicklung ist auch extrem zyklisch.
Es ist ja auch schön, dass diese Leute, die das machen, auch mit so einer enthusiastischen Naivität an Dinge rangehen. Weil wir haben das Ding ja zusammengeschraubt und unser Vermieter, der seit 25 Jahren Maschinen und Installationen baut und Erfahrung hat in Mechanik und Konstruktion, guckt sich das an und sagt gleich, das hätte ich aber so gemacht. Das ist ja irgendwie total wackelig. Also im Wesentlichen viele Dinge, die jetzt da sozusagen neu entwickelt werden, hätten vielleicht gar nicht neu entwickelt werden müssen, wenn man Fracht der Ahnung hat. Aber ich meine, das ist ja zum Glück nicht ausgeschlossen. Das sind ja genau diese Momente, wo jemand sagt irgendwie, hier dank Open Source und alles hier, das ist ja eine gute Idee, aber hier an der Ecke ist das ja echt scheiße, ich mach das mal richtig. Und dann fließt es hoffentlich wieder ein. Und das ist ja auch bei der Software eigentlich ein schönes Versprechen, was Open Source angeht. Und ich hoffe, das passiert dann natürlich auch, dass genau Leute sagen hier, das ärgert mich jetzt hier, aber dass das nicht so gut ist, dass ich verbessern werde.
Also zum Beispiel dieser Druckkopf von diesen Rap-Raps und Make-Up-Bots, die haben halt Versionsnummern. Also wenn du halt irgendwie so einen, von einem der vielen Anbieter so ein Ding kaufst, dann steht dabei, ist halt ein Rap-Rap-Hat-Version, also ähnlich Version 4. Steht dann halt dabei und dann weißt du, naja, der ist dann schon halbwegs okay, weil da kann der Stepper zum Beispiel den Tick zurückdrehen, um dazu zu verhindern, dass der Tropfen unten an der Düse hängen bleibt.
Also da tut sich was, sozusagen.
Also Hardware mit Version ist dann einfach die Richtung.
Aber wie praktisch ist denn so ein Teil? Ich meine, es ist sicherlich ganz nett, dass man da mal so ein bisschen glibberige Plaster aufeinander machen kann, aber hat das, was dabei rauskommt, schon irgendeinen Wert, also einen Nutzwert?
Die Frage ist halt, was du damit tun willst. Wenn du jetzt hier zum Beispiel deine Rolls-Royce-Bataste bauen willst, dann kannst du dir damit halt das Gehäuse für deine Rolls-Royce-Bataste bauen. Dann kannst du dir halt überlegen, gehe ich hin und designe mir mein Gehäuse selber, damit es genauso ist, wie ich es haben will.
Aber wie schäbig sieht das da aus, wenn es da rauskommt? Ist das ein bisschen so selbst gestrickt aus?
Nein, das ist halt, was aus dem RepRap kommt, hat erstmal keine glatte Oberfläche, das ist halt so ein bisschen ruppelig, weil halt diese Fäden sind. Wenn du jetzt noch Mighty Mouse-Polish haben willst, musst du halt nachpolieren.
Man erhält sozusagen so ein wirklich grobes Grundraster von dem, was es mal sein könnte.
Genau, wenn du jetzt sagst, ich will jetzt irgendwie das Aluminium haben, kommst du zu uns und wir fräsen das, dann sieht es halt geil aus. Dann kann es halt auch richtig ordentlich aussehen.
So eine Fräse hat schon was, ne?
Ja, deswegen haben wir zuerst eine Fräse gekauft.
Jetzt hatten wir den Make-up-Bot-Kostenpunkt mit 750 Euro inklusive allem. Und was habt ihr so in diese Fräse investiert?
Naja, so 3.500, so etwa. Das ist halt so der, wie gesagt, kann man halt auch nur zu mir.
Okay, Faktor 4, aber macht auf jeden Fall schon mal einen signifikanten Unterschied.
Genau, man kann auch billigere kaufen, wir wollten aber was haben, was auch steil bearbeiten kann. Das war halt so der Ansatz, wegen der Fahrradgeschichte, dass wir halt auch in der Lage sein können, was baut ihr dann damit? Primär machen wir momentan halt Dinge, die, was ist so was, die Drehmoment stützen oder so eine Sachen, also Dinge, die, also Kleinteile, die man braucht, um halt den Motor ans Fahrrad zu adaptieren. Wir haben auch eine Menge Motorradschrauber, die bauen sich halt auch alle möglichen Teile, die sie halt sonst nicht kriegen können oder die sonst für 50 Euro aus dem Katalog verkaufen, wenn aber 3 Euro Materialwert haben. Also so eine Sachen sind halt so momentan der Fokus und natürlich eine Menge Frickelei an dem Gerät selbst. Also halt verbessern, was weiß ich, zum Beispiel Roboter gerade eine Drehzahlsteuerung ein. Also dass man halt die Drehzahl von der Spindel halt präzise kontrollieren kann.
Wie fein ist das? Kann man sich damit so eine Schraube machen? Kriegt man so ein Gewinde dahin?
Das ist halt immer die Frage, welches Gerät nimmst du für welchen Zweck? Also mit einer Fräse kannst du flächige Teile produzieren. Eine Drehmaschine benutzt du zum Beispiel, um Gewinde zu machen oder so. Wir haben so eine kleine Drehmaschine, die ist noch nicht fernsteuerbar. Kann man aber selber noch den ganzen Kram ranmachen.
Also das Problembereich Schrauben ist an sich schon mal auch ohne CNC ein gelöstes Problem.
Das ist halt auch mal die Frage, was tust du? Wenn du zum Schraubenladen gehen kannst und dir deine Schraube für ein paar Cent kaufen kannst, dann investierst du halt nicht den ganzen Tag darin, dir eine Schraube zu drehen. Das machst du nicht. Das machst du nur, wenn es die 3,16 Zoll Schraube ist, die jetzt gerade in dein Motorrad muss, die du halt einfach nicht kaufen kannst.
Genau, oder um so eine antike Maschine zu fixen, wo es halt einfach...
Ersatzteile ist dann auch noch so ein Ding, was dann, glaube ich, jedenfalls mit den Geräten, die sozusagen im Profibereich da sind, vielleicht einfach auch so diese Ersatzteillagerung für einige Sachen einfach ablösen könnten.
Das ist ja auch immer so ein Ersatzteilservice.
Also wenn du so guckst, wovon die ganzen Buden, die so Laser-Cutting oder Waterjet-Cutting oder auch CNC-Fräsen anbieten als Dienstleistung, gibt es ja reichlich. Also kannst du hingehen mit deinem 3D-Modell, dann machen sie das, du kostest halt nur Geld. Und ein großer Kundenstamm von denen sind Oldtimer-User. Also Leute, die einen Oldtimer haben und dafür Ersatzteile halt einfach nicht mehr kriegen, weil es den Herstellern nicht mehr gibt. Oder der Hersteller von Auto 2020 vielleicht nicht mehr supporten möchte. Und dann gehen sie halt dahin, bringen kaputte Teile mit und lassen sich das halt nochmal neu machen. Also so viele von den richtig alten Oldtimern bestehen mittlerweile zum Drittel aus, irgendwie 10 Segefrästen neu teilen.
Ja, es könnte dann auch gewisse Dinge dann auch wirklich billiger machen, weil man eben nicht mehr ein großer Hochregallager braucht, um allen möglichen Scheiß 30 Jahre lang zu lagern, bis es dann endlich mal in Ankauf ist.
Also speziell für Sachen, wo die Produktionsstückzahl gering ist, lohnt es auf jeden Fall. Also mein Maschinenbau ist auch mittlerweile total üblich. Schiffbau zum Beispiel ist ja immer ein Unikatbau oder Kleinsäenbau. Die machen halt extrem viele Teile, auch in so repaporte Typing-Geschichten.
Gibt es ja noch andere Geräte, die jetzt interessant sind, um Hardware zu machen, außer jetzt diesen Fräsenbeispiel und diesen Klebepistolen-Robotern?
Lasercutter ist halt so das nächste Spielzeug, das eigentlich alle haben wollen. Die Wiener MetaLab haben ja schon einen und haben damit viel Freude. Da ist halt das Problem, dass leistungsbedingt die Lasercutter, die man sich momentan im Hobbybereich leisten kann, selbst mit irgendwie viel guten Willen, nicht in der Lage sind, Metall zu schneiden. Sondern das ist tatsächlich auf organische Materialien weitestgehend beschränkt. Das ist unsere Plaste, Holz, Papier, Pappe, so eine Sachen.
Also Lasercutter, wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Das ist im Prinzip so ein Schneewittchensack, wo dann Laser drin ist und dann schickt man den Laser irgendwie. Der kann aber immer nur ganz durchmachen.
Der kann auch gravieren.
Der fokussiert sozusagen an einem Punkt und da brennt es weg.
Du kannst die Laserstärke einstellen. In der Regel funktioniert es so, dass der Laser festpunktiert ist und du dann über zwei oder drei Spiegel eine Ablenkung hast aufs Werkstück. Du fährst mit einem XY-Schlitten wie beim Plotter. Nur mit einem Plotterstift fährst du halt einen Spiegel. Auf dem Plotter-Schlitten ist ein Spiegel, der den Laser auf die richtige Achse bringt und dann wiederum runter aufs Werkstück.
Also man fährt Spiegel durch die Gegend?
Genau, man fährt Spiegel durch die Gegend und der Laser liegt drum. Es gibt auch welche, die einen Faserbündel durch die Gegend fahren in der Industrie. Wenn du halt so brutale Infrared Laser hast, da kommt dann halt so ein dickes Faserbündel, wo der Laser durchheizt, weil das ist halt völlig unbezahlbar.
Was für einen Preisbereich bewegen sich Laser-Cutter?
Also der billigste China-Cutter, den wir jetzt so in der Planung oder wie auch immer haben, ist so bei 1000 Euro für so ein 40-Watt-Gerät mit schrecklicher Software. Da muss man noch eine ganze Menge selber dran frickeln, bis er richtig tut.
40 Watt ist schon viel?
40 Watt ist schon so, dass du Plaste ordentlich bearbeiten kannst und Holz und solche Sachen problemlos cutten kannst und alles andere gravieren kannst.
Wie groß können die Werkstoffe dann so sein?
Das ist halt immer eine Preisfrage für die Billigen. Das sind so 20 x 30 cm meistens. Also A5 etwa ein bisschen größer.
Und für so ein gutes Gerät, was A2 oder mehr bearbeiten kann.
Das sind schon einige 10.000 Euro.
Da gibt es kein neues Auto sozusagen.
Gibt da mal ein paar coole Beispiele, was man jetzt so mit einem... Also bei der Fräse, denke ich mal, ist irgendwie klar, alles, was man so an Metallwerkstücken sich erdenken kann, das passt da ganz gut rein. Bei dem Lasercutter mit Holz und Kunststoff.
Also typische Anwendung ist zum Beispiel Frontplatten gravieren. Also wenn du halt irgendwie dir ein elektronisches Gerät bauen willst und die Frontplatte ordentlich beschriften willst, dass du die da sauber reingravieren kannst. Die Buchstaben sieht halt sehr schick aus. Und hat auch eine gewisse Haptik. Die haben Telefone gravieren. Die Leute markieren sich halt ihre Telefone, ihre Computerdeckel, also Individualisierung halt. Dann gibt es eine Menge so Spielzeug-Bastel-Kits, die aus Pappe oder Plastikscheiben so zusammenstecken, Geschichten sind so. Das ist halt wiederum ein Ergänzungsding. Man baut sich halt so einen kleinen Fuhrpark an Werkzeugmaschinen auf. Und durch deren Kombinationen man dann wiederum Sachen machen kann. Manchmal geht es ganz billig, wenn man 50 Euro vom Flohmarkt eine Spindelpresse holt. Das ist so ein Ding, das nichts weiter tut, als einen Stempel brutal nach unten drücken mit vier Tonnen Kraft über eine Art Wagenheber-Mechanik. Dann drehst du halt und dann ist da so eine Schraube dran. Diese Schraube ist so richtig fast so armdick. Die drückt dann halt zum Beispiel einen Stempel in ein Stück Blech, sodass du halt ein Blechgehäuse formen kannst. Oder ein Plastetief ziehen kannst.
Oder deine Initialen in den Gürtel.
Genau, so was auch immer dir halt irgendwie einfällt. Flohmarkt ist halt ohnehin der Gold-Tipp sowieso. Wir sind halt da auch immer häufiger unterwegs.
Mit dem Laser Cutter, wie gesagt, dieser Wrap-Wrap-Druckkopf, der besteht ja jedenfalls auch in der Version, die da für ein Make-Up-Bot verkauft wird, im Wesentlichen aus Plexiglas-Scheiben, die alle auf dem Laser Cutter geschnitten sind. Das heißt, es ist ein Modell, das sie sich so ausgedacht haben, dass sie die Funktion eines faustgroßen Objektes in Scheiben zerlegt haben und diese Scheiben einzeln ausgeschnitten haben. Das heißt, du hast links und rechts zum Beispiel so eine Abschlussplatte und dazwischen sind verschieden ausgeschnittene Platten. Das Ganze wird so zusammengeschraubt, aufeinandergestapelt und da passen dann der Motor und ein Zahnrad und alles genau rein. Das heißt, es ist so ein, ich weiß nicht, wie man das nennt, so ein Konstruktionstest. Das heißt, man kann damit keine dreidimensionalen Objekte ausschneiden, man kann aber, wenn man es mechanisch so verkaufen kann, dass man es, dass es sich in Schichten bauen lässt, vielleicht wie so ein Uhrwerk oder so, wo ja auch die Zahnräder jeder in so einer Ebene liegt.
Dann wird es einfach miteinander verklebt?
Ja, oder verschraubt und verklebt und so weiter. Und ansonsten habe ich jetzt also so mitbekommen hier Martin Bauer, der so einen Laser-Service im Wedding betreibt, lasernlasern.de, der kriegt halt sehr viele Anfragen von Leuten, die damit einfach Dinge machen, die halt innovativ sind. Also manchmal irgendwelche geil aus irgendwie Papier oder schicken Material in gelaserten Eintrittskarten oder Pokale oder sowas, einfach weil es geht. Also auch weil, man könnte natürlich auch vieles davon auf einer Fräse machen, aber es geht relativ zügig auch da in Sachen Prototyping, so dass du sagst, na dann lasern wir das einmal und dann macht dieses Ding halt so schwisch, schwisch, schwisch und ist dann irgendwie nach zwei Minuten fertig und man hat es dann in der Hand. Das hätte man natürlich auch von Hand mit der Laubsäge oder gesteuert mit der Fräse, mit viel Dreck machen können. Das hat schon was sehr Futuristisches, dass du einfach so eine Maschine hast, schiebst so ein Stück Plastik rein, drückst auf den Topf und dann macht so was.
Das ist weder laut noch dauert es lange sozusagen.
Stinkt halt nur ein bisschen.
Ja, weil das alles wegverpufft.
Ja gut, da muss man natürlich die richtige Lüftung dran haben.
Lüftung, also der Laser-Cut, das Lüftung und Kühlung, das ist der wichtige Punkt.
Aber muss man für die Kühlung das selber sorgen, oder wie?
Der Laser muss gekühlt werden. Also in der Regel sind so die größeren, also eigentlich fast alle Laser-Cuts, die gerade auf dem Markt sind, Wasser gekühlt. Also früher gab es da Luftgekühlte, aber die meisten sind heutzutage Wasser gekühlt. Da ist hinten so eine Aquariumpumpe dran, die dann so ein bisschen Wasser dadurch...
Aber ich meine, im Vergleich zu, wenn man sich so eine eher dreckige Materialwerkstatt vorstellt, ist das schon was sehr, sehr Sauberes.
Das ist schon designerkompatibel, ja.
Es ist schon so ein Ding, was denn einfach noch kein Replikator ist und es arbeitet ja auch nur zweidimensional im Wesentlichen, aber es hat schon...
Spritz leuchtet auch noch dabei.
Es ist eher so... Es ist eher vielleicht wie so ein Laserdrucker, dass du im Wesentlichen ein Material hast und irgendwie kommt das Werkstück am Ende raus.
Wenn ihr da mit eurer Fräse am Werken seid, muss das dann die ganze Zeit da irgendwie mit Wasser bespritzt werden?
Hängt vom Material ab, also so in Holz und auch in Aluminium kann man eigentlich ohne Kühlung fräsen. Bei Stahl geht es halt ohne Kühlung nicht ab.
Und dann muss das so ein Ölbad oder was?
Ja, das ist so eine Kühlpumpe, die da draufgemacht wird. So eine kleine Sache machst, kannst du noch bei Hand mit der Ölkanne nachkühlen, also einfach ein bisschen Schneidöl nachmachen. Aber wenn du größere Sachen fräst, dann muss man da halt schon richtig mit Kühlmittelpumpe und dem ganzen Kram arbeiten. Dann wird es halt auch ein bisschen eklig. Der Schmatterfaktor ist dann schon da hinten.
Okay, also man sollte sich vielleicht, wenn man sein Hackerspace da aufbaut, als erstes Mal Gedanken über Entsorgung von irgendwelchen schleimigen Substanzen machen, eine Wanne drunter bauen oder so.
Genau, also Lüftung ist ein Problem. Natürlich Spritzschutz bei Fräse muss halt sein. Die sollte halt nicht im selben Raum stehen wie irgendwie andere Sachen so.
Ist noch nicht so in dem Sinne, dass alle Kreativen gemeinsam in einem Raum sitzen. Wenn der eine denn da codeet, kannst du nicht daneben.
Nee, Fräsen ist auch laut. Also wir haben halt Glück, wir haben eine Raumfahrtagentur. Das ist halt eine ehemalige Arztpraxis. Wir haben also ein Röntgenzimmerchen drin mit so einer tollen Sichtscheibe. Und da haben wir halt die Fräse untergebracht. Und das ist ganz gut, weil wir haben jetzt einen so separaten Raum. Man kann von draußen nicht die Scheibe gucken. Das ist ganz...
Und das ist auch strahlengeschützt sozusagen.
Ja, zumindest behauptet der Vormieter.
Okay, also ferngesteuerte Heißliebe-Pistolen, ferngesteuerte Fräsen, CNC-Technik, im Prinzip auch alles mehr oder weniger. Die kostengünstigen Varianten aus dieser industriellen Prototyping-Branche. Beim Lasercutter weiß ich gar nicht. Lasercutter auch so in einem Industrie-Prototyping-Bereich.
Also da gibt's natürlich dann noch sehr viel mehr. Also im richtigen Industrie-Lasercutter kannst du ein Blech schneiden. Du bist durchaus zu erheblichen Stärken.
Ja, und diese Sinter-Dinger, die wir ja schon besprochen haben. Da kommt dann irgendwie Laser und Plaste wiederum zusammen.
Wenn du mehr Material wegmachen willst, bei Metall nimmst du einen Wasserjet-Cutter. Das heißt, da ist halt eine gigantische Pumpe, die Wasser auf Druck bringt. Und das wird dann durch eine ultradünne Düse gehauen. Und da ist halt so viel Energie dahinter, dass du richtig Metall damit wegmachen kannst. Also damit kann man halt richtig so durch relativ dicke Bleche schneiden und so. Es gibt dann auch sehr saubere Kanten, weil das Wasser dann so wegschmuggelt.
Und es kühlt auch gleich.
Genau. Es ist halt tolle Technologie, aber es ist momentan auch noch so in der 150.000 Euro-Kategorie. Die Pumpen sind halt nicht so klein. Also das ist halt nochmal so eine Zehnerpotenz dicker als so ein Karcher von der Pumpenleistung her. Verstehe.
Die haben da so richtig viel Bar.
Ja, genau. Das ist halt richtig. Es gibt natürlich noch eine riesige Vielzahl von anderen Rapid-Prototyping-Technologien. Also zu meiner Lieblingstechnologie ist zum Beispiel Funken-Irodieren. Ich finde das Wort so toll. Funken-Irodieren. Das muss man einfach lieb haben.
Was heißt das? Das wird da mit elektrischem Strom weggeälzt oder was?
Na, weggebratzt.
Weggebratzt.
Also tatsächlich, du hast halt so ein Draht und dann wird dein Werkstück negativ, dein Draht positiv. Und dann fährst du mit dem Draht da lang und bratzt halt winzige Stückchen Metall aus dem Ding raus.
Auf jeden Fall immer schön Finger weg.
Das erinnert mich nur gerade an die Vergangenheit, weil vor fast zehn Jahren, als ich das erste Mal für jemand anderes eine Webseite gemacht habe, als man so was noch machte, weil man einen Vorsprung hatte an Informationen, war das für eine Irrudierfirma. Und ich hatte damals überhaupt nicht geblickt, was das eigentlich für komische Maschinen sind. Und jetzt kommt es quasi alles wieder zurück. Also nicht kommt wieder zurück, aber thematisch sitzt sich auf einmal in so was drin.
Gut, dann legen wir doch mal jetzt die Hardware so ein bisschen beiseite, also zumindest die Hardware, die jetzt so Dinge macht. Du hast ja vorhin schon gesagt, Frank, ja, die Hardware und die Software. Die Hardware ist ja ganz teuer, aber die Software stinkt. Aber es wird besser. Ansteuerung ist...
Wie gesagt, also Ansteuerung ist halt so ein Ding, das ist jetzt mit diesem Lienungs-CNC löst sich. Das ist so flexibel, dass man da alles ranhängen kann, was man an Maschinen hat. Also es wird halt für alles benutzt, Drehmaschinen, Lasercutter, Fräsen, irgendwelche merkwürdigen riesigen Portal-Fräsen, mit denen sich Architekten, Stadtmodelle fräsen, das ist völlig unklar. Die größte Fräse, die benutzt wird, wird im Schiffbau benutzt. Die fräsen da so Spanten für irgendwie so Hochleistungssegelboote mit, die dann so irgendwie richtig groß sind. Also das kann ich nur dringend empfehlen. Das ist halt auch eine Software, die sehr dynamisch weiterentwickelt wird und wo man eigentlich fast alles ranfrickeln und ran basteln kann, was man möchte.
Ich wollte jetzt mehr so hinaus auf sozusagen auch Software selber als Bastelobjekt, wo man also jetzt einerseits natürlich Dinge steuert, aber jetzt gar nicht mehr nur die Dinge steuert, die dann selber was bauen sollen, sondern wo sozusagen das Steuern auch das eigentliche Ding ist, was man sich jetzt so erbasteln will. Da hat sich ja auch parallel eine relativ große Community aufgetan in den letzten Jahren. Vor allem versammelt sich eine ganze Menge hinter dem Arduino-Projekt. Konntest du da was zu sagen, Philip?
Arduino ist ein Open-Source-Micro-Controller-Board. Nichts, was per se eigentlich was großartig Neues ist. Also viele Hardware-Hacker oder so beschäftigen sich eigentlich schon ewig damit. Es ist halt so ein kleiner Atmel-Chip da drauf, der ein kleiner Prozessor ist mit Speicher und so weiter. Das Ganze, wie soll man sagen, relativ freundlich verpackt auf einer kleinen Handtellergroßen Platine mit Anschlüssen über USB an den Rechner angehängt. Und was daran eigentlich einfach ist, oder es ist einfach was, was ich schön finde, es kommt einem so ein bisschen entgegen der modernen Informationstechnik. Man hat ein Modul, man steckt es über USB an den Rechner, klickt in seiner Software, wo man programmiert auf Upload und das Programm ist dann da drin. Und dann hat man einen entweder autark agierenden kleinen Kleinstcomputer, der natürlich mit allerlei Geschichten Daten austauscht, der sich sehr gut eignet, um sensorische Daten aufzunehmen, um was weiß ich, irgendwelche Motoren, Lichter, andere Geschichten anzusteuern, aber auch Internet, was weiß ich, Daten aufzunehmen, sie irgendwie zu visualisieren oder an den Rechner verbunden bleibt und da irgendwie als so eine Art allgemeines Adapter-Board für alles Mögliche dienen kann.
Das heißt, Herz der ganzen Geschichte ist sozusagen ein Hardware-Design, ganz konkret so eine kleine Platine, wo der Prozessor drauf ist, wo eine Basis-Software drauf läuft und das Ding hat dann irgendwie analoge digitale Ein- und Ausgänge und eine USB-Schnittstelle dran, über die sozusagen wesentlich die ganze Kommunikation läuft. Sonst noch mal was?
Na, es ist halt ein Open-Source-Dings, also es kam aus dem Wunsch heraus an einer italienischen Designhochschule, irgendwie, dass die Designer sagten, wir würden hier gerne mal für diese und jene Installation oder Kunstwerk irgendwas Interaktives haben, können aber nicht quasi erstmal Informatik studieren oder uns mit den Feinheiten von Mikrocontroller-Programmierungen auseinandersetzen. Und dann hat sich sozusagen genau solche Leute, die sie halt nicht sein wollen, gesagt, ok, dann entwickeln wir euch das mal. Und es ist halt, ich finde, deutlich einfacher, damit zu arbeiten. Viele Leute, glaube ich, auch gerade, die sich mit solchen Sachen seit langem beschäftigen, gucken da etwas mitleidig runter, weil sie sagen, ja, ist ja dasselbe wie immer, nur halt quasi...
Also der Unterschied ist, dass sie es halt einfach wirklich zu Tode getestet haben. Also es ist halt so, dass der... Also es gibt ja eine Menge solcher Mikrocontroller-Bastelboards, die man sich bestellen kann, von denen einige auch eine relativ große Community haben, wenn man es halt mal einfach haben will, aber die haben alle eine sehr hohe Einstiegshürde. Also das ist halt so, dass der, bis man den Kram ans Laufen kriegt und dann wiederum Sachen supported bekommt, was ich immer mal irgendwie schnell in ein LCD-Display ran häkeln will oder dergleichen Dinge mehr. Es ist halt immer Gefrickel, Datenblatt lesen und so, nicht mal, ich will eigentlich mein Problem lösen und mich nicht damit beschäftigen, wie das LCD-Display da ran gemacht wird. Und beim Arduino ist es so, da gibt es halt so eine riesige Community, die auch so aktiv ist, dass das neue Hardware dazubauen zu dem Projekt halt sehr simpel ist. Du kaufst dir halt einfach nur das richtige LCD-Display, lädst sie dir die Blut-Tick runter, steckst sie dran und es geht. Und das ist halt so, ich hab dir schon mal erzählt, ich hab meinem Sohn so ein Ding gekauft auf dem, wie heißt der? Egal.
Du warst irgendwann mal da.
Genau. Und ich hab ihm einfach in die Hand gedrückt und gesagt, hier, probier mal. Bring noch mal ein paar LEDs zum Blinken. Das ging halt, 20 Minuten später. Ich musste nix machen. Sie hat sich das runtergeladen, die Software an die Züge drangeschaltet, ein Beispielprogramm geladen, kurz rübergeguckt, gelesen, wie es mit dem Koden geht. Und dann ging das.
Wie programmiert man das?
Das ist so ein C-Dialekt.
Ja, wie gesagt, das Arduino-Projekt ist im Wesentlichen einmal die Hardware und einmal die Software. Das ist dann so ein Java-basierende IDE im Wesentlichen, sehr, sehr simpel, die C ist mit so ein paar tollen Funktionen, dass man halt schreiben kann, hier schalte den Eingang ein, also mit einem Befehl. Und ich finde das gut, dass es relativ skalierbar ist, in dem Sinne, dass derjenige, der sagt, okay, aber ich hätte das lieber gerne hardwarenah entwickelt, dann sagst du ihm, ja, ist ja auch einfach nur so ein Standard-Admin-Board, du kannst das beliebig kompliziert ansteuern und auf der Kommandozeile Videos gerne hast. Aber demjenigen, der sagt, ich habe aber eigentlich ein Projekt hier und mein Fokus ist eigentlich, ich würde gerne etwas bauen, das dies tut, dem kommt das, glaube ich, ganz gut entgegen. Und für den einen oder anderen kann es auch einfach gut genutzt werden, um ihn zu verführen, natürlich sich dann tatsächlich mehr damit zu beschäftigen, aber man muss es halt nicht.
Und das Schöne ist halt, das nimmt einem dieses ganze Hardware, also Low-Level-Hardware-Prototyping aus der Hand, was wirklich nervig ist. Also wenn man halt sich so anguckt, so wie man Hardware entwickelt, dann ist es halt häufig eine ziemlich teure, ziemlich nervige Geschichte, wo man hier wieder was vergessen hat und da wieder was vergessen hat. Und dann wutet der Mikrocontroller nicht, weil irgendwie er mit irgendeinem Tag nicht happy ist. Und da passiert halt, ich nehme so ein Arduino-Board, schalte es an und es geht einfach so. Und du kannst dich halt nur darum kümmern, den Input-Output zu machen, den du haben willst. Und das ist halt eine echt große Leistung. Du kannst einen Künstler in die Hand drücken, erklärst ihm den Tag und dann kann er damit sein Projekt machen. Das ist halt schon echt toll.
Vor allen Dingen, weil was ich irgendwie früher gesagt hatte, dass viele Leute einfach gar nicht denken, dass sie in dem Bereich was selber machen können. Nach dem Motto, ich kann hier für meine Installation das Gehäuse bauen und ich kann irgendwelche Bilder malen. Und dann sagt irgendwie der Künstler, aber wie das denn alles interaktiv sein sollte, keine Ahnung. Das können nur Hacker oder so. Das ist dann einfach so ein Ding, wo du sagst, hier, das ist aber wirklich...
Genau, ist nicht schwieriger als Flash.
Ja, das ist auch, glaube ich, so, dass jetzt mittlerweile so eine Generation von Leuten nachwächst, die jetzt nicht mehr so diese klare Trennung machen mit, ich bin nur so der Künstler, der irgendwie konzeptioniert. Und dann suche ich mir da so meinen Coding-Slave und er setzt das dann oben und am Ende des Tages hat man festgestellt, dass der Hackerleiter sozusagen die eigentliche Wertschöpfung betrieben hat, während der Künstler dann nur so seine Ursprungsidee reingemacht hat, sich dafür feiern lässt, was ja auch irgendwo in Ordnung ist. Aber man merkt dann aber auch immer so, also mir ging das zumindest immer so, dass wenn diese Projekte dann sozusagen nicht wirklich auch von demjenigen, der es eigentlich ersonnen hat, auch durchimplementiert wird, dass dann irgendwie was fehlt. Dass es irgendwie so einen Disconnect gibt zwischen der tatsächlichen Implementierung und dem ursprünglichen Anspruch. Weil wenn man halt selber viel mehr sich damit beschäftigt, man auch auf einen ganz anderen Weg kommen würde. Das ist nicht so verkopft, sondern man versteht das Wesen der Maschine besser, um es dann besser anzupacken.
Das hat was mit begreifen zu tun auf jeden Fall, dass man dann auch nicht nur sagen kann, oh, jetzt ist was kaputt an meinem Kunstwerk oder an meinem Objekt, keine Ahnung. Es ist ja genau diese Demokratisierung, dass du einfach sagen kannst, du kannst die Hardware tatsächlich selber in die Hand nehmen, selber programmieren, selber zusammenstecken. Eigentlich finde ich es auch schön, wenn man das Gefühl hat, Leute haben wir, dadurch kriegen sie ein Verständnis für Geräte, die einen ja auch immer mehr umgeben. Das ist auch eine Umächtigung auf eine Art und Weise, dass man sagen kann, ich verstehe ein bisschen mehr, wie das, was mich eigentlich umgibt. Also nicht nur hier im Podcasting-Studio ist man von Technik umgeben, sondern überall sonst. Ich finde es immer gut, wenn Leute auf die eine oder andere Weise plötzlich verstehen, ach so, da wird ja auch nur mit Wasser gekocht. Wenn man selber mal so ein Bit von der Hardware in die Software zurückgeschickt hat, dann ist das auch soweit entzaubert auf eine gute Art und Weise, dass man sagt, ja, klar, mach ich selber.
Demokratisierung des Produktionswissens, den Begriff habt ihr jetzt irgendwie schon beide gebracht, beim Baustellen steht da sozusagen auch als fetter Untertitel. Ist ja schon irgendwie ein recht, ja, schon ein fettes Statement irgendwie.
Das stammt aus der gleichen Nacht, wo man sich den Namen Baustellen ausgedacht hat und das ist jetzt einfach mal so geblieben, auch wenn ich öfter mal auf die Webseite gucke und mir überlege, was das eigentlich genau heißt und so auch.
Naja, aber ich meine, so mit Demokratisierung würde ich jetzt zunächst einmal natürlich auch ein bisschen die Machtfrage verbinden. Wenn etwas demokratisiert werden soll, dann macht das so den Eindruck, als ob das ja vorher von einzelnen Diktatoren beherrscht wird.
Die Marxisten haben ja immer gesagt, dass das Eigentum an Produktionsmitteln der kritische Punkt ist. Also wenn du Produktionsmittel hast, dann kannst du Mehrwert schaffen und dann kannst du den Mehrwert, den du daraus ziehst, als Profit in die Tasche stecken. Das wäre die marxistische Theorie. Der interessante Punkt ist, dass durch die Möglichkeit, über den Preis und die Kooperation Produktionsmittel wieder selber in die Hand zu nehmen, entsteht zumindest auch mal ein Bewusstsein für diesen Prozess. Ich will nicht sagen, dass das dazu führt, dass sich die Welt wieder zurückentwickelt dahin, dass alle demokratisch ihre Produktionsmittel in der Hand haben. Aber sie haben zumindest für gewisse Teilbereiche die Möglichkeit dazu. Sie können auch einfach besser verstehen, was es bedeutet oder eben nicht bedeutet, Produktionsmittel in der Hand zu haben und wie viel menschliche Arbeit tatsächlich noch wert ist und wie viel schon von Maschinen gemacht wird. Das ist ja auch am Ende eine der Kernfragen, die wir als Gesellschaft beantworten müssen, ist, ob wir in der Lage sind, die Automatisierungsdividende zu vergesellschaften, also in der Lage sind, den Gewinn, den wir durch Roboterisierung und solche Geschichten bekommen. Es ist ja nicht mehr so, dass Arbeitskraft dazu führt, dass Mehrwert geschaffen wird, sondern Maschinenkraft schafft Mehrwert. Die Konzentration von Reichtum, die wir beobachten, dass also immer mehr Reichtum bei immer weniger Leuten konzentriert wird, hat damit natürlich genau zu tun, dass die immer weniger Leute tatsächlich noch mit ihrer Arbeitskraft richtig dollen Mehrwert schaffen, sondern immer nur so ein bisschen. So diese ganze Dienstleistungsgewerbe hat ja nicht umsonst so beschissene Stundenlöhne. Es liegt halt einfach daran, dass der Mehrwert, den die meisten Leute da schaffen, eher gering ist im Vergleich zu so einem Roboter. Das sind halt so Ideen und Gedanken, die einem beim Umgang mit der Thematik auch einfach kommen, wo man einfach mal eine Runde drüber nachdenken muss. Das finde ich ist noch so ein wichtiger Aspekt, der auch zum Verständnis beiträgt, von was eigentlich gerade passiert in dieser Welt.
Ja, und wie gesagt, mit dieser Konzentration geht ja dann auch einher, dass dann immer unklarer wird, wie ist das eigentlich entstanden, was ich da habe. Ich finde, das hat auch etwas Aufklärerisches, wenn du einfach sagst, das basiert einfach auf, ist vielleicht sehr komplex, wie irgendwas industriell hergestellt wird, aber es basiert auf Schritten, die man vielleicht zu teilen, auch nachvollziehen kann und auch replizieren kann sozusagen. Und wie gesagt, es geht in Richtung von mehr Wissen für den Einzelnen. Es geht auch natürlich in die ganze Richtung, was Open Source so ein bisschen auch als Konzept über Software hinaus ist, dass man einfach in die Dinge reinschaut.
Und dass wir uns Sachen auch einfach nicht verbieten lassen. Also es ist halt so, dass, wenn man sich so anguckt, wie sich die Patentunwesen entwickelt, wird der immer schlimmer, sodass man eigentlich de facto, wenn man heute ein Start-up anfängt und sich neue Sachen ausdenkt, müsstest du eigentlich theoretisch erst mal damit anfangen zu recherchieren, ob nicht irgendjemand deine Idee schon mit irgendeinem doofen Trivial-Patent gecovert hat und dann mit dem zu reden. Und diese ganze Selber machen Bewegung ist davon halt einfach ausgenommen. Weil für dich selber kannst du immer machen, was du willst. Ich hab so viele Patentschriften gelesen wie noch nie in meinem Leben, einfach aus dem Grund, weil er gucken kann, wie machen sie es denn eigentlich. Es steht halt in den Patenten drin. Das kann ich für mich selber natürlich einfach problemlos nachvollziehen und machen, ohne dass mir dabei irgendjemand was kann.
Solange du es nicht kommerziell einsetzt.
Solange ich es nicht kommerziell verkaufe, genau.
Ich finde es aber auch wichtig, dass es einfach so ein weiterer Baustein ist, um wieder in die Köpfe von Leuten auch reinzukriegen, dass man nicht unwichtig ist als Einzelner. Dass es auch einfach ein kleines Ding ist. Aber manchmal sind es ja solche Sachen, die man im Leben erlebt, die einen so ein bisschen nachhallen, dass du einfach nicht machtlos bist auf irgendeine Art und Weise. Das kann sich auf verschiedene Sachen äußern. Aber das Gefühl, das kennt man ja auch in Hackerkreisen, das habe ich selbst gemacht und irgendwie das konnte ich. Das ist gar nicht so unwichtig.
Genau, also das Gefühl von Wiederermächtigung.
Hach, das ist ja schon ein super Schlussthema jetzt hier eigentlich. Es gibt glaube ich schon noch ein paar Sachen, die man auch noch so an Produktionsmitteln vielleicht noch erwähnen sollte. Was mir gerade so einfällt, ist dieses Fritzing-Projekt. Das kennst du auch, ne? Das geht auch allen im Prinzip auch in diese Open-Source-Schiene rein.
Ja genau, also die sehen sich als schönes Ergänzungsprojekt auch zum Arduino auch so. Also man kann sehr schön visualisieren, wie man Schaltungen baut.
Also da geht es um Elektronik bauen.
Genau, also das ist ja im Wesentlichen eine Open-Source-Software, die so eine Art Tool ist, um auf einem Bildschirm Schaltungen zusammenzustecken. Mit Fokus im Moment halt sehr stark auf Arduino, der da sozusagen als digitales Modul drin vorkommt. In der Roadmap kann man sehen, die wollen es halt schon auch stark erweitern. Über das Business-Modell bin ich mir natürlich nicht so ganz im Klaren. Die Idee bei denen war halt mal, du baust dir eine Schaltung an dein Arduino, vielleicht hier auf dem Tisch so mit Steckbrett und so und sagst, das ist jetzt gut. Das hätte ich gern so, dass es nicht auseinanderfällt. Ich klick mir das in der Software nochmal zusammen, kann dann auch nochmal ein bisschen gucken, okay, das sieht auch gut aus. Dann kann die Software dann auch so grundsätzliche Routing-Geschichten machen, wie so ein Platinen-Layout-Programm und bringt dir das dann so auf so eine Platine, die du halt direkt auf dem Arduino steckst.
Also simuliert jetzt nicht auch die Funktionen?
Also die sind aber im Moment bei Version 0.3.1 und das geht immer schon.
Da geht es noch eine Weile vorwärts, ja.
Das ist auch ein Uni-Projekt aus Potsdam und die machen natürlich auch Arduino-Kurse und tragen in die gleiche Richtung sozusagen. Das ist eigentlich sehr schön daran.
Gibt es dann außerdem Arduino noch andere erwähnenswerte Projekte, die so in die gleiche Richtung zielen?
Dutzende. Was jetzt gerade so diesen ganzen Mikrocontroller-Bereich angeht, ist das Feld einigermaßen unüberschaubar. Man muss halt einfach, wenn man anfängt, sich da so einen Mikrocontroller auszusuchen, gucken, wie groß die Community ist, also wie viel Drive hinter so einer Community steht.
Aber ich finde ja, dank offener Standards und so ist das, muss man es gar nicht mehr so dogmatisch sehen wie früher, wo du gesagt hast, ich kaufe jetzt hier das eine Gerät oder das andere Gerät, sondern man geht am Ende, oder was ist am Ende, man gewinnt immer an Wissen, wenn man sich da mit beschäftigt und wenn man dann sagt, ja hier habe ich ja einiges gelernt am Arduino, ich brauche jetzt für ein Projekt aber ein Ding, das Dinge liefert, die ich da nicht kann, dann fängt man ja nicht bei Null an, sondern dann nimmt man Wissen mit und Konstruktion. Also im Wesentlichen, es wird nie weniger, das ist eigentlich das Schöne daran.
Wenn jetzt Leute so ein bisschen auf den Geschmack kommen, ihren schon existierenden Hacker-Space, sagen wir mal mehr in Richtung Hardware-Bauen auszubauen oder überhaupt erst mal so ein Projekt zu starten, habt ihr da so ein paar Tipps? Welche Fehler man möglichst gleich von Anfang an vermeiden sollte? Oder wie man da zumindest auf seine Regeln kommt?
Also das Wichtigste sind halt die Leute. Man sollte halt nur mit Leuten sich zusammentun, wo man ein gutes Gefühl hat. Das ist halt so die Grundregel, dass man nicht denkt, ach, das wird schon gut gehen, sondern wenn man denkt, naja, ob ich mit dem zusammenarbeiten kann, weiß ich nicht, dann sollte man darauf hören. Und laufen genügend willige und interessante Leute draußen rum, dass man sich nicht mit Leuten abgeben muss, die dann hinterher doch irgendwie merkwürdig, egomanisch sind oder nicht in der Lage sind, sich in so einem Hacker-Space vernünftig zu bewegen. Und der zweite ist halt wirklich Mut zu haben. Wir haben halt auch zu viert die Idee gehabt und einfach mal rumgefragt, wie er denn noch so Bock hat und ist gerade die Zeit reif. Wir wollen echt viele Leute so weit machen.
Was ich noch wichtig finde, weshalb ich mich an diesem Hacker-Space-Konzept, also wie von Jens und Lars sozusagen, gibt es ja dieses Hacker-Space-Manifest, da reibe ich mich manchmal ein bisschen dran, weil ich da manchmal das Gefühl habe, es wird schwierig, wenn man noch das Ziel hat, mal gucken, ob man noch Leute, die eigentlich in der Lage wären und Lust hätten, mit sowas in Kontakt zu bringen. Also so ein bisschen das idyllitäre Ding, nach dem Motto, wie können wir, wenn wir das wollen, schaffen, dass man auch Leute reinzieht, die eigentlich gar nicht wissen, dass es sowas gibt, die aber vielleicht genau sowas suchen, die einfach nicht aus diesem selben Diskurs kommen. Also ich finde das manchmal ein bisschen schade.
Man muss es ja nicht unbedingt Hacker-Space nennen. Es gibt ja auch, wie war das in den USA, diese Orte, wo es jetzt wirklich nur darum geht, diese Maschinen zu aggregieren und zu teilen. Ja, wie zum Beispiel diese Tech-Shops. Das ist jetzt sozusagen ein konkreter, ich glaube da noch irgendein Begriff, der mir gerade entspunnt ist. Aber das ist ja sozusagen dann auch erstmal so von der Hacker-Community als solcher auch unabhängig.
Ja, ich glaube, man muss halt gucken, wo da die Grenzen liegen. Vielleicht geht es auch beides in einem Ort, dass man sagt, wir haben hier unsere Crew und dann haben wir vielleicht Zeiten oder irgendwie eine Möglichkeit, Leuten auch eine Dienstleistung vielleicht anzubieten. Oder dass man sagen kann, guck mal, hier jeden Sonntag oder Mittwoch oder was auch immer, versuchen wir sozusagen neue Leute auch für Dinge zu begeistern. Oder vielleicht auch ganz stupide, dass jemand sagt, ich muss hier sowas gefräst haben und gebe euch Geld dafür. Also es geht vielleicht nicht alles immer in das gleiche Konzept in jedem Ort, aber man muss ja auch nicht so ganz kleinteilig denken, sondern was natürlich schön wäre, wenn einfach mehr Leute sich solche Konzepte aneignen. Und man steht ja nicht unbedingt komplett in Konkurrenz zueinander, wenn man sagt, hier guck mal, wir haben jetzt hier in Prenzlauer Berg so ein Ort und dann haben wir in Neukölln so ein Ort. Und der eine macht so, der andere macht so. Ich finde das halt schön, wenn man so das Gefühl hat, dass es auch normaler wird. Also da ist der Bäcker und da ist der Friseur und daneben ist dann halt dein Tech-Shop oder dein Hackspace oder dein Coworking und irgendwie so ein Mittelding zwischen allem. Vielleicht jeder mit einer anderen Ausrichtung, weil er auch individuell betrieben wird. Aber so, dass die Leute dann sagen, naja, okay, und wenn ich hier was gefräst haben will und danach dann noch irgendwie einen Kaffee trinke, gehe ich halt dahin. Dass es einfach auch rauskommt aus diesem, oh, da sitzen irgendwelche Jungs im Labor und die machen da irgendwas Sinistres und tragen Pullis mit RF-ähnlichen Logos.
Ja, also das ist denke ich mal ein wichtiger Aspekt, ist halt einfach die Vielfalt der Modelle ist groß und da muss man halt einfach seins finden, also worauf man Bock hat. Und ein Thema zu finden, also eine Sache, die die Leute inhaltlich zusammenbringt, ist halt schon mal wichtig. Und dementsprechend hängt dann auch eine unglaubliche Menge tatsächlich von Infrastruktur ab. Also ob die Infrastruktur geeignet dafür ist, dort zu tun, was man möchte. Also zum Beispiel, wenn du halt fräsen möchtest, dann musst du halt einen Raum haben, wo du nachts laut sein kannst. Weil es hat halt keinen Sinn, das irgendwo in einem normalen Wohnhaus zu machen, wo du halt darüber eine Familie mit Kindern hast. Und dann willst du nachts um halb drei tatsächlich mal kurz Stahl fräsen und das ist halt einfach laut. Das sind halt so Constraints, die man halt beachten muss. Und, naja, wie gesagt, die Botschaft ist halt einfach Mut haben zum Anfang. Also es gibt genug Platz zumindest irgendwie in Berlin noch. Ich weiß nicht, wie es in anderen Städten ist. Aber der Drive der Leute, wenn sie halt einmal anfangen zu sagen, wir bauen jetzt hier mal unser Ding und das ist so, die Ausrichtung ist halt schon ziemlich enorm.
Und jetzt so an konkreten Sachen. Also ich meine, jetzt haben wir natürlich das eine oder andere Gerät schon hier besprochen, was so ganz, wie soll ich sagen, verlockend ist. Aber es muss ja jetzt auch nicht unbedingt jetzt gleich die CNC-Fräse sein. Was ist sozusagen eine sinnvolle Grundausstattung, der man auf jeden Fall schon mal auch kalkulieren sollte?
Das war's schon. Es lässt sich ja beliebig skalieren.
Eigentlich braucht man nur einen Hammer. Weiß man auch gleich, wie man alles einschlägt.
Ich glaube, je nachdem, was du für eine Klientel hast, kannst du auch mit einer offenen Werkstatt ganz klassisch schon was reißen, indem du einfach Leuten sagst irgendwie hier nach Motto, ich hab hier die Säge, die du nicht hast. Und von da geht es halt je nach Budget und je nach Geschichte nach oben. Also man muss ja nicht gleich irgendwie gucken, dass man da 100.000 Euro hat, dass man in alte Geräte entwickelt hat, obwohl es natürlich eine tolle Sache ist. Das ist ja auch so diese Idee bei diesen Fab Labs, also diese Idee von, wie heißt der, Neil Gerschenfeld, Prof an der MIT, dass du halt so Orte hast, die halt moderne Werkstätten mit diesen modernen Geräten sind, also 3D-Drucker, Lasercutter, Zentral und was noch, Fräsen bestimmt auch. Dass du einfach so einen Ort hast, der, wie ich gerade gesagt habe, einfach da ist, so hier ist der Bäcker und da ist das Fab Lab und da gehst du halt rein und druckst dir dein Ding und gehst dann wieder nach Hause oder so. Und da gibt's, also ich war mit im Team, die so eine Veranstaltung jetzt gemacht haben vor ein paar Wochen, die Atoms und Bits hieß, lustigerweise. Ach ja, richtig, da haben wir das ja gesehen. Im Nachhinein ist uns, oder mir jedenfalls dann aufgefallen, dieses MIT-Zentrum heißt ja natürlich Center for Bits and Atoms, was sicher bei wem auch immer, wir konnten nicht mehr rekonstruieren, wer eigentlich den Veranstaltungsnamen irgendwann auf der Pfanne hatte, irgendwie im Hinterkopf war. Aber darum geht es ja genau, also die Atome Bits, dass ja diese schöne Verbindung hat und Software und wie das ineinander übersetzbar ist. Und da auch spontan Leute aufgetaucht, die sagten hier, Fab Labs, ganz toll, interessiere ich mich jetzt für. Michael heißt aus Nürnberg. Und jetzt gibt es halt so über E-Mail Kontakt mit ein paar anderen Leuten noch Bestrebungen, neue Info, Achtung, ist noch geheim quasi, dass irgendwie Anfang nächstes Jahres so ein Barcam-artiges Ding passieren soll zum Thema Fabbing. Das ist ein Wort, was gar nicht so gefallen ist, aber das ist immer ein Schlagwort, was diese Geräte angeht.
Ich meine, das, was ihr jetzt so beschreibt, was die Raumfahrt-Agetur und so weiter ist, da würde ja der Name Fab Lab auch schon ganz gut passen. Aber ihr verwendet den jetzt so eigentlich nicht. Na, ich weiß nicht, ist ja immer gut, wenn man mal was Griffiges hat, weil wir haben ja gemerkt, HackerSpace hat ja auch noch so ein paar ganz andere Konnotationen. Das passt da zwar auch mit rein, aber es hat jetzt nicht so dieses Hardware-Bastel- und Werkstatt-Charakter im Mittelpunkt.
Na gut, Fab Lab ist bezeichnend halt auch schon ziemlich spezifisch, dieses MIT-Projekt insofern. Ja, aber der Name ist schon gut eigentlich.
Okay, aber es hat sich so oder so noch nichts wirklich herausgebildet, was jetzt so der Name ist für diese Werkstattbewegung?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie der rechtliche Status von Fab Lab ist. Das sagen manche Leute halt so, aber dann war es im Wesentlichen aus der Literatur. Und weil dieses genaue Projekt so heißt, da weiß man natürlich nie irgendwie, wenn ich sowas hab, was das gleiche in grün ist, darf ich das auch so nennen. Das müssen wir einfach nochmal rausfinden. Aber es ist natürlich ein schöner, toller, kurzer, sich reibender Begriff und so. Aber wie gesagt, da gibt es vermutlich in Bremen irgendwann Anfang 2010, also gar nicht mehr so weit hin, Termin gibt es noch nicht, so ein kleines Barcamp von Leuten, die sich in Deutschland mit diesem Thema auseinandersetzen. Und ich bin da noch nicht so richtig drin, aber es gibt wohl Bestrebungen, einmal in Nürnberg und einmal in Bremen, dass da Leute sind, die gerne sowas auf die Beine stellen. Das heißt, was denn irgendwie so ein Ort ist, der so einen Mischcharakter hat aus Hacker-Space, offener Werkstatt, Ort, an dem man hinkommt mit seinen Problemen und seinen Ideen und gemeinschaftlich schaut, wie man sie realisieren und umsetzen kann.
Aber um nochmal so in praktischem Bereich zu bleiben, was die Selbstorganisation betrifft, unabhängig von den Geräten gibt es bestimmte Prozeduren und Sachen, die sich bei der Raumfahrtagentur ganz gut gemacht haben. Mir fallen jetzt so einfache Sachen ein, wie dass man für das Werkzeug ein dickes Brett an die Wand nagelt und jedes Werkzeug einmal mit einem Edding abmalt, dass man weiß, da kommt es normalerweise hin und heute fehlt es.
Dass jedes Werkzeug seinen Platz hat, hat sich auf jeden Fall bewährt. Das ist wichtig, auch dass man klar sagt, das ist ein Werkzeug für die Allgemeinheit, das alle benutzen können. Das ist hier mein privates Werkzeug. Das wird z.B. nach speziellen Einweisungen bedarf, oder empfindlich ist oder mordsteuer ist, was ich jetzt nicht möchte, dass es jeder benutzt.
Hat dann auch noch jeder seinen eigenen Spind?
Genau, dass es da einen Platz für jeden gibt. Das sind so Sachen. Wichtig ist, dass die Kommunikation innerhalb des Projektes möglichst transparent ist. Wenn man einen Raum länger als einen Nachmittag belegt, dass man kurz vorher ins Blog schreibt oder ins Wiki oder auf die Mailing-Liste, je nachdem welchen Stil man bevorzugt, dass das gerade so ist und warum es so ist, einfach kommunizieren und Ansagen machen und nicht einfach voraussetzen, dass die anderen nicht gerade zufällig in dem Nachmittag da auch was machen wollten. Das ist eine ganz wichtige Geschichte.
Wie gesagt, wir haben eine Werkstatt, aber die ist erst kürzlich so ein bisschen entmüllt. Und das geht jetzt gerade erst los, die auch als Werkstatt zu nutzen. Also da, wo ich sitze, habe ich zwar quasi meine eigene Ecke mit Lötkolben und dem ganzen Kram. Aber da ist es dann zwar keine Hardware-Arbeit, aber das ist genauso wichtig, dass halt klar wird, oh, morgen ist ab 16 Uhr hier aber was anderes. Oder kommunizieren ist super wichtig und einfach auch genau die Klärung, was ist gemeinschaftsgut auf eine Art und Weise und was ist privatgut. Also da gibt's dann auch Spinde oder Regale, wo dann einfach klar ist, wenn du gehst, dann räum hinter dir auf und solche Geschichten. Und wenn du irgendwie hier was nimmst, dann tu da Geld in die Kasse. Also eigentlich normale Verhaltensregeln. Aber klar, man probiert's aus und stellt mal fest, das eine funktioniert nicht. Zum Beispiel das mit der, nimm dir hier eine Mate aus dem Kühlschrank und tu da einen Euro rein. Das ist so eine Sache, die hinkt im Moment bei uns, weil da eine Diskrepanz ist. Und da muss man einfach mal gucken, wie man das einfach hinkriegt. Aber es hängt auch stark von Leuten ab und wie offen es ist. Wenn dann irgendwie Leute reinkommen, die man kennt, ist es okay. Wenn andere Leute reinkommen, dann muss man immer gucken, nicht jeder führt ins Böse.
Ich glaube, man fängt halt erst mal an, sein RFID-basiertes Ausleih- und Bezahlsystem zu implementieren. Dann hat man schon mal so ein Startprojekt.
Das ist genau die Sache. Die Hefte der Ideen, die wir gerade haben, das sind eigentlich genau solche Projekte, die müsste man mal machen. Und natürlich bleiben die auch oft mal hängen aus Zeit und sonstigen Mangel. Klar, aber die Ideen sind halt da. Aber das ist Erfahrungssache. Ich glaube auch, wenn mehr solche Orte entstehen, dass da auch mehr Kommunikation entsteht.
Ja, ich sehe da eine Menge. Mir fällt gerade dieser Hacker-Space in Toronto ein, wo ich neulich war. Die haben dann auch erst mal angefangen, sich ein Zugangssystem zu bauen, wo man dann auch gleich persönlich begrüßt wird. Das hat natürlich erst mal so ein gewisses Hack-Value, aber ist natürlich auch super praktisch. Alleine auch um diese Zugangsgeschichte zu regeln und dann irgendwie weg von dem wer hat einen Schlüssel, wer hat keinen Problem.
Ja, das ist glaube ich auch das erste, was bei uns ansteht. Das andere war die Idee, wir bauen uns eine Art Getränkeautomaten mit billigen Mitteln. Sprich Kühlbox im Keller und den Aufzug. Aber ich glaube, das scheitert daran nicht. Ja, so eine Mato-Rohrpost in der Richtung. Um zu vermeiden, dass man sich bei Ebay für 1000 Euro einen richtigen Getränkeautomaten kauft, würde man dann sehr viele Mannstunden darauf verwenden, sich das selber zu bauen. Aber das macht ja auch Spaß, klar. Aber solange das noch nicht so ein Ding ist, wo man sagt, das ist jetzt hier von neun bis fünf mein täglicher Beruf, hier rumzuschrauben und trotzdem nicht arm zu werden, ist das noch ein bisschen schwierig.
Ja, das war schon ein ganz guter Roundup. Haben wir noch etwas ganz Wichtiges vergessen zu erwähnen?
Noch mal auf die realen und virtuellen Zettel gucken.
Du hast vorhin noch so einen Begriff von Recycling und Upcycling fallen gelassen. Was verbirgt sich dahinter?
Upcycling ist die Idee, dass ausgediente Konsumgüter zu anderen immer noch nützlichen Konsumgütern modifiziert werden können. Das ist halt so eine Idee. Bisher gibt es nur sehr wenige Beispiele, wo das in der Praxis wirklich gut funktioniert hat. Meistens wird dann das ausgerolltete Konsumgut immer nur zu Kunst oder zu irgendwas, was mal eine gute Idee werden könnte, aber dann doch in der Ecke steht und verstaubt. Aber die Idee dahinter ist einfach zu sagen, viele Sachen, die wir heutzutage haben, enthalten zumindest Bauteile, die wir noch verwenden können. Typisches Beispiel sind Steppermotoren. Die können wir überall verbauen, in Maschinen, Werksfällen, was auch immer. Die sind in Druckern drin, in Floppis drin. Überall sind Steppermotoren drin, die können wir einfach rausholen und die kriegen wir in der Regel immer noch angesteuert. Das ist halt so das einzige Beispiel, was ich kenne, was gut funktioniert, sind Leuchtioden rausholen und Steppermotoren.
Was weiß ich, so Magnetschalter oder so.
Ja klar, man kann immer noch Bauteile und Einzelteile bergen und weiterverwenden.
Aus einem kaputten Kopierer kriegst du ein guter Werkzeug raus, den man weiterverwenden kann. Ist natürlich immer so die Frage, habe ich jetzt einen konkreten Nutzen?
Geht es in den Allgemeinen funnlos?
Oder mache ich ein Stepper-Motoren-Museum auf?
Nee, aber es sind ja auch immer die Tendenzen, dass man sehr viele Dinge verwahrt, die man irgendwann noch mal brauchen kann.
Genau, also eine gut sortierte Materialkisten-Sammlung ist echt wichtig. Wenn solche Teile auf den Schrott wandern, dass man noch birgt, was daraus zu verwenden ist, und es einfach archiviert, wenn man es später verwenden kann. Vermutlich. Häufig genug archiviert man auch Müll, das passiert halt, aber immer mal wieder kann man es später doch noch brauchen. Es ist halt weder gut sortierte Fahrradladen, der hat halt auch eine große Kramkiste, wo er halt die Teile von den alten Fahrrädern drin hat, weil irgendwann kommt jemand des Weges, der es noch braucht.
Man muss natürlich aufpassen, dass er die tolle Werkstatt nicht gleich zu so einem Lager verkommt.
Genau, also Platz hat man nie zu wenig.
Nein, dieses Upcycling?
Nie zu viel, Entschuldigung.
Das ist richtig, dass mir auch selber wenig Dinge einfallen, die nicht im Bereich Kunst ändern. Also im schlimmsten Fall so Schrott-Skulptur, was ja auch manchmal ganz nett sein soll. Gestern auch bei Etsy gesehen, jemand baut niedlichste Roboter aus Schrott. Aber das ist ja, damit endet ja sozusagen, denn fast der Nutzen nichts gegen Kunst und gegen schöne Geschichten. Aber es ist noch nicht so das Ding, dass du sagst, ist ja geil, lass mal hier die ganzen alten Geräte anschaffen. Wir machen da was richtig Tolles draus. Weil es bleibt immer noch sehr viel Müll übrig, selbst wenn du denn aus dem Kühlschrank nur das eine Teil brauchst oder so. Und das ist ja auch, ich glaube, das ist auch so ein Ding, was vielleicht auch in Amerika, angesichts des schlechteren Recyclings, da besser funktioniert. Also diese ganze Dumpster-Diving-Geschichte, ich fahr irgendwie sonntags auf den Hof und hole mir denn von der Firma den ganzen geilen Scheiß aus dem Container, das geht hier schon gar nicht mehr, weil das ja, was ja eigentlich eine gute Sache ist, für die Umwelt, aber wenn du da nicht gerade irgendwie bei der BSR rumsitzt und dann irgendwie versuchst, Dinge rauszufiltern.
Also hier Stadtreinigung, da bei den Wertstoffhöfen und so, da versuchen irgendwie noch die Sachen abzugreifen.
Ich hab gehört, die hier in Prenzlauwerk sind da ein bisschen lockerer. Weil das ist ja immer so die Sache, in dem Moment, wo du es weggeschmissen hast, gehört es ja der BSR.
Und du meinst, dass man da einfach mal in den Wertstoffhof reingeht, wo die ganzen Leute ihre alten Drucker reinschmeißen und da mal so ein bisschen was aus dem Container ziehst?
Ich glaube, ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es natürlich in Deutschland ein rechtliches Problem auch in dem Sinn ist, dass... Nein, klar, aber ich denke mich da gerade so in diese Mentalität rein und in dem Moment ist es nicht nur eine Eigentumsfrage, sondern auch irgendwie, wenn ich es der BSR gebe, dann habe ich es ja quasi entsorgt.
Oder wenn du dir den Finger klemmst beim Motor aus dem Drucker raus holen.
Ja, oder, dann...
Dann schon lieber e-veilen, mal gucken, was für Bastler ist und die Flomärkte.
Am Ende könnte ja der ursprüngliche Entsorger die BSR noch verklagen, weil er es ja...
Weggeworfen hat.
Ja, und es ist aus dem Verkehr und plötzlich sind da geheime Daten, oder was weiß ich, wieder da. Alles schon passiert. Auf Flomärkte, Schrottplätze, wenn es sowas noch gibt, wird ja auch weniger.
Das war Basteln im 21. Jahrhundert. Mal gucken, vielleicht sehen wir ja noch sehr viel mehr solche Orte aufkommen. Ich bin gespannt, was sich da noch alles an lustigen Geräten macht. Wird jetzt beim kommenden Kongress irgendwie... Gibt es da wieder so eine Ecke, weißt du das, Frank?
Ich habe gerade keinen Überblick.
Okay, kann aber sein.
Ich würde denken, dass da einiges ist, aber ich habe gerade keinen Überblick.
Ich habe mich noch nicht so richtig mit dem Kongress befasst, aber...
Sonstige Veranstaltungen, die vielleicht mal erwähnt werden, außer diesem Barcamp, was du erwähnt hast, hat sich noch nicht so richtig... Ich meine, es gibt ja in den USA, gibt es ja dieses Make-Magazin und dann auch diese Maker-Fair, die, wie ich gehört habe, ich war nie da, schon wirklich zu einer Mammut-Veranstaltung geworden ist, wo dann viele tausend Leute nicht nur besuchen, sondern auch viele hunderte ausstellen und irgendwie allen möglichen...
Ich hoffe mal, dass es so was sich auch ergibt, diese Überlegung, die da mal zu dieser Veranstaltung Atoms & Bits geführt haben, vor ein paar Wochen, da gab es vor Überlegen, einfach so ein DIY-Festival zu machen und dann wurde das aber erstmal als irgendwie massenmäßig und arbeitsmäßig erstmal zu groß angesehen. Dann haben wir uns quasi mit dieser größer angelegten Atoms & Bits-Veranstaltung damit reingehängt im Wesentlichen. Da habe ich mich dann so ein bisschen um den DIY-Teil gekündigt und das ging aber auch um die Zukunft der Arbeit, um Kunst, um Dinge, die sozusagen diese Internet- und Stoffwelt transzellieren.
Die Veranstaltung fehlt sozusagen noch in Europa, wo man mal die ganzen Stricker- und Schnittmusterbögen-Austauscher zusammenbringt mit Fräsensteuerern und anderen Wahnsinnigen.
Bisher passiert das im Kleinen. Wir haben mal einen Workshop gemacht mit Leuten von der Havanda, also die Filzer und Stricker und näher zusammen mit den Lötern. Das waren natürlich genauso die einen, wir waren nur Jungs, die anderen waren nur Mädels, sag ich. Und das ist natürlich auch so eine Sache, an der man auch ein bisschen arbeiten muss.
Na, man hat schon mal einen Ansatz, um da so ein bisschen Geschlechtsparität herzustellen.
Ja, nee, die Idee ist auch super. Ich hab da natürlich aber nicht Stricken gelernt am den Tag und die anderen auch nicht irgendwie Elektronik grundlagen. Weil dann natürlich jeder mit dem beschäftigt ist, das zu tun, was er kann. Aber dass da noch ein stärkerer Austausch passieren sollte, finde ich total wichtig.
Na gut, dann machen wir jetzt mal hier den Deckel drauf. Und ja, das war's. Und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und ich erwarte eure Kommentare wie immer im Chaosradio Blog oder ihr schickt eine Mail oder macht was auch immer. Und ja, hier geht's auch bald wieder weiter oder macht eine Wave. Macht mal Welle oder vielleicht baut ihr auch einfach mal eure eigene Werkstatt zusammen und fangt auch mal an, hier mit Lasern und ferngestellten Heißklebepistolen lustige Sachen zu schnitzen. Gut, ich sag dann Tschüss und bis bald bei Chaosradio Express. Auf Wiedersehen!